RESPONSE TO COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY ALL
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
WILL BE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
LEMONADE IN ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASKED THAT EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU USE THEIR RAISE YOUR
HAND FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM.
EACH TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO UN MUTE. PLEASE SELECT
THE ME BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR IT PERSONNEL WILL
PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU
ARE DONE ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN. STATE
YOUR NAME AND THEN YOU'RE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE OR WAS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR
YOU CLEARLY HAD TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM. DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE HERE IN
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER. AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES WHERE PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN BE HEARD. IN
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL COVER
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. WE HAVE
PANELISTS FROM THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WILL PRESENT ON THESE
ITEMS PLEASE NOTE THAT THERE
ARE NO ITEMS THAT WILL BE VOTED
ON TODAY. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE PRESENTATION OF THE TRIAL
COURT OPERATIONS UPDATE I WILL
BE HEARING FIRST FROM THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. PLEASE WELCOME
WHOEVER WILL BE SPEAKING. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON SIR MY NAME IS
ROBERT HOW YOUNG I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND I WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH A QUICK UPDATE
ON A SURVEY THAT WE RECENTLY
CONDUCTED ACROSS THE COURTS
REGARDING THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ON COURT OPERATIONS-
SO I JUST WANTED TO MENTION
THAT. THE COURTS WERE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE DURING THE
PANDEMIC THROUGH TECHNOLOGY AND
OTHER OPERATIONAL ENHANCEMENTS-
THAT REALLY HELP MAINTAIN SELF
ACCESS- FELT SAFE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE- MOST COURTS
IMPLEMENTED NEW TECHNOLOGY
SOLUTIONS PROVIDE A REMOTE AND
ONLINE SERVICES- WHILE THE
COURT USER SHELTER IN PLACE OR
WORK FROM HOME- SELF HELP
CENTERS REMAIN OPEN NOW AND
PROVIDE- THE MAJORITY OF
ASSISTANCE OF REMOTELY PRETEND
THAT MAKE ABOUT 90% OF THE
POPULATION. VISITORS TO THE
COURT I CAME INTO THE SELF HELP
CENTERS- PHYSICALLY FACE TO
FACE AND NOW THAT HAS SHIFTED.
TO SOME 5% OF THE VISITORS
YOURSELF COMING REMOTE SO THAT
HAS PROVIDED A VERY IMPORTANT
METHOD- TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
ACCESS TO THE PUBLIC TO OUR
SELF HELP. CORP SLOWDOWN- ARE
PRIMARILY DUE. TO THIS THING
AND FOR THE SOCIAL REQUIREMENTS-
AS WELL AS SOME. ON WORKFORCE
ABILITY OF THE. THE- WORKFORCE
OF WITH- DUE TO WE DO DO TO US
WORK SHE AND RE DIRECT THAT
WOULD ABOUT FIVE TO TEN FOR OF
THE- SHIFTING TO. AND THEN
RELAY ACT SUCH AS ADDITIONAL
KLAY. OUR TEMPERATURE CHECK
ADDITIONAL REQUIRE TO INSURE
THAT THE COURT HOUSES WERE
SAVED AND TO ACCOMMODATE REMOTE
PROCESS AND- DUE TO PANDEMIC
RELATED ABSENCE AND THE 10% OF
BUDGET CUTS- IN THE CURRENT
YEAR- THAT ALSO AFFECTED SOME
WORKFORCE DAYS OF BEING
REDUCED. IN TERMS OF JUDICIAL
OFFICER AVAILABILITY THAT WAS
NOT SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
PANDEMIC RELATED LEAVES- AND
ALSO JUDICIAL OFFICER
ASSIGNMENTS ARE FOR SPECIFIC
CASE FIVE REMAINED CONSISTENT
DURING THE PANDEMIC. COMPARED
TO PRE PANDEMIC LEVELS. OUR
CONTINUING FOR CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL- THANK ON AVERAGE BY
ABOUT ELEVEN. WITH CIVIL BEING
AFFECTED A LITTLE BIT LESS THAN
CRIMINAL CASES- THE AVERAGE
DAYS A LAPSE FROM THE FILING TO
DISPOSITION FOR CIVIL UNLIMITED
CASE WHICH INCLUDES- THE
COMPLEX CIVIL INCREASED BY
ABOUT EIGHTEEN PERCENT. AND
THEN FINALLY CHANGES IN THE
AVERAGE NUMBER OF HEARINGS- PER
CASE FOR CIVIL CRIMINAL AND
TRAFFIC REALLY VARIED BASED ON
LOCAL CONSTRAINTS AND PROCESS
CHANGES SO IN SOME CASES THE
NUMBER OF HEARINGS INCREASED.
ARE SOME STAY THE SAME AND IN
SOME CASES ARE THE NUMBER OF
HEARINGS ACTUALLY DECREASE. BUT
THAT'S A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
HOW THE COURTS HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED BY THE PANDEMIC- I'LL
ASK- THIS NANCY EVERHART- TO
COMMON ON OF THE DETAILS
OPERATE EXAMPLE FROM WITH.
THANK YOU MISTER YOUNG- YOUNG
AND MATT CHAIRMAN OF THE- THIS
NEW YOU EVER HEARD OF EXACT
OFFICER SAM TO DINO SUPERIOR
COURT AMONG CHAIR OF THE CORTEX.
OF COMMITTEE AND MEMBER OF QUE.
THE SURVEYS AND THAT I GATHER
EXPERTS OF THE COURT IN A WAY
WE CAN BE TO SEE COMMON TO. IT
HEALTH SAFETY NEEDS SHALL ABOUT
TO GO KOBE IMPACT IN THE UP. TO
REMAIN. THE WORK OF THE COURT A
FURTHER INTEREST YOU BESIDE THE
TRIAL COURT SIR. IS A PANDA
CONTINUITY OF OPERATIONS
RESOURCE GUIDE DEVELOPED IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL IN TRIAL COURTS IT'S
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE. WE
CAN ALSO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
RECEIVE THAT. BUT THE EMERGENCY
ORDERS AUTHORIZED. AUTHORIZING
MORE OPTIONS THE COURTS WERE
ABLE TO EXPAND REMOTE ACCESS TO
HEARINGS. REMOTE SELF HELP
FARMS COMPLETION ELECTRONIC
FILINGS DIGITAL EVIDENCE
DOCUMENT ROUTING SIGNATURES AND
EVEN INVESTIGATION DUTIES
AROUND CONSERVATORSHIP
GUARDIANSHIPS IN CHILD. SUPPORT
AND ALSO VISITATION. WE'RE
COMPLETING THAT OF K. FIRE HERE
EACH DAY. IN LA WHERE SIX COURT
HOWEVER MY TECH. UPWARDS OF
THOUSAND CASES ARE HEARD REMOTE
PER DAY. IN JANUARY TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND LITIGANTS PARTICIPATED
UNLIMITED CIVIL PROCEEDINGS. IN
SAN DIEGO A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
COURT ROOMS HAVE REMOTE
TECHNOLOGY HEARING AROUND A
THOUSAND CASES PER DAY. IN
SANTA CLARA JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
IS COMPLETELY REMOTE. IN
CURRENT THEY PARTNERED WITH
JUSTICE PARTNERS TO COLLABORATE
AND MAKE REMOTE HEARINGS A
REALITY WHERE IT WASN'T BEFORE.
AN ORANGE COUNTY THEY'VE BEEN
ABLE TO MAKE CURRENT SMALL
CLAIMS IN TRAFFIC MATTERS. MY
COURTS AS WELL AS SANITARY LOS
ANGELES AND OTHER COURTS HAVE
PUSHED PUSHED FORWARD REMOTE
SELF HELP OPTIONS. WE LAUNCHED
A NEW DIGITAL ACCESS SELF HELP
PLATFORM TO HELP SELF
REPRESENTED LITIGANTS ACCESS
FORMS WORKSHOPS LIVE CHAT VIEW
FILES HAVE DOCUMENTS REVIEWED
AND COMPLETED IS. THE BEGINNING
OF OUR PROCESS HERE LOCALLY SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY USERS
REGISTERED FOR ASSISTANCE. BY
JUNE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY NINE WERE
ADDED. THE TOTAL FOR MARCH
THROUGH DECEMBER OF
202-400-0800 AND SEVENTY EIGHT
WITH AGAINST REACHED OUT FOR
REMOTE ASSISTANCE. MANY COURTS
ARE SHARING SIMILAR STORIES.
CHIEF JUSTICE IS CHARGED TO
SEARCH FOR A 310060 DEGREES
ACCESS OPPORTUNITIES THIS
HAPPENING NOW. THIS IS PAINFUL
EXCEPT EXTENDABLE AND EXCITING
AND A WAY FORWARD TO MODERNIZE.
ACCESS TO JUSTICE. AS MR YOUNG
MENTION HEALTH AND SEE IS OUR-
YEAH SIGNIFICAN FACTOR. IN THE
COURTS A BILL TO MAKE SERVICE
LIKE ALL. THE TRIAL COURTS HAVE
A- IMPLEMENTED MASK ORDER SO
DISTANCING. SIGNAGE DELIVERY I
TRIAGE. CALENDAR MAY. AND CLEAN
TEMPERATURE IN HELPS. SEPARATE
THIS BARRIERS SUCH AS PLEX.
REMOTE WORK. SHIFTS MOVEMENT OF
STAFF AND JUDGES JURIES CREATE.
AND SPACE LET JUST OR EVEN IN
ALL TURN FACILITIES. WE
REALLOCATED STAFF RESOURCES. TO
CODED BY PER MANAGEMENT
PROMOTED PERRANCE MONITOR.
EXPANDING CENTER. EXPANDING
SERVICES NOTICING AND NOTICED
BLUE HEARING AS NEW HEALTH OR
AND CLOSE WERE WERE OUT EACH
DAY. MANY OF OUR STAFF HAVE
BECOME TRACERS AND IMPLEMENT
NEW LAW AND- AROUND EXPO NOTED.
CHORDS EVERY L. STAY TO WORK
TIME I WEEKEND. PROVIDING
TRACING ARE ALSO LEE A SYSTEM
IS AN- FOR EXAMPLE IN LA NICE
TO OF BEING REAL. TO WORKERS
CONTACT RAY AND COUNTY SIX
SANDY FIVE EXEMPTS DINO FOR.
ADDING AND SAFETY MEASURES COME
A HUGE MONEY AND RESOURCE FOR.
COST COURTS AND WE HAVE TO
DIVERSIFY FROM A UP. AT MY
COURT ENHANCE YOUR- IS TH EXTRA
MONTH. IN L. THE COST IS OVER
FIVE MILLION TO. DIMINISHED
ACCESS THE COURT AND BACK ARE
RESULT OF MANY FOR. STEPHAN
JUDGES HAVE NOT BEEN OF TO WORK
DUE TO. CO REASON SCORE WITH.
SCHOOL AND DAY CARE CLOSURES.
AND SOME STAFF AND JUDGES HAVE
HAD TO RETIRE QUIT THERE ARE NO
OTHER ON. IN OTHER OF TWENTY
TWENTY BEFORE THE BIG HOLIDAY
SURGE FORTY SEVEN COURTS
REPORTED LOST AFTER DAYS IN A-
CORE REPORTER LAST YEAR NETWORK.
AT HIGH POINT IN THE SUMMER MY
COURT A HIGH OF THIRTY BECAUSE
OF CASES WITH ONE HUNDRED. AT
WEDNESDAY WE ALSO HAVE ONE
COURT CLOSURE. NORINCHUKIN ONE
CAN RESULT IN FORTY CONTRACTORS
SAYING INVESTIGATIONS. IN SANTA
CLARA AND ENTIRE DEPARTMENT WAS
QUARANTINE BACKING UP WORK IN
THAT CASE TYPE FOR OVER TWO
WEEKS. LA IS REPORTING SIMILAR
ISSUES. OUR ARE EGGS. DELAYS BE
SEEN AND BY. TIME TO TELEPHONE
WAY TIMES. ACCESSING FILES HOST
OF OTHER CORE FUNCTIONS.
RESOURCE A STRETCH FURTHER
SEVERE COURT BUDGET READ THE
SPECIFICALLY. CALENDARS ARE
REDUCED 22225% OF AVERAGE
CAPACITY DUE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. THE TYPICAL COURT
ROOM SHOULD HOLD FIFTY PEOPLE.
WITH SOCIAL DISTANCING ELEVEN
PEOPLE IS THE MAXIMUM CAPACITY
INCLUDING JUDGES AND STAFF SOME
OF OUR OLDER COURT ROOMS REALLY
ONLY FIFTY FIVE. MANDATORY IN
PERSON HEARINGS IN JURY TRIALS
HAVE SLOWED AND CALENDARS MUST
FREQUENTLY BE CONTINUED- AS MR
YOUNG REPORTED OUR CONTINUANCE
IS HIGH IN MANY CASE TYPES AND
JUROR CHAU RIGHTS ARE PURPLE
CHAU ARE. CURRENTLY I HAVE 11%
SHOW RATE FOR JURORS IT USED TO
BE ABOUT 30% REMOTE PROCEEDINGS
HAVE HELP BRING MATTERS FORWARD
AUTHORIZED BUT THEIR STAFF AND
TIME INTENSIVE- PURCHASING AND
CONTRACTING FOR SERVICES
INSTALLATION OF EQUIPMENT
TRAINING REMOTE MONITORS.
SETTING UP CALENDARS QUALITY OF
CONNECTION AND USER KNOWLEDGE
ARE ALL CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
MEETING. THE COURTS AS A WHOLE
HAVE PERFORMED HEROICALLY TO
SHIFTING RESHEF CORE FUNCTIONS
YOUR ADDRESS MULTIPLE
CHALLENGES SINCE THE ONSET OF
CO THAT NINETEEN. WE HAVE
REINVENTED AND MAINTAIN ACCESS
AS CO THAN A BUDGET CHALLENGES
HAVE ALLOWED THE ANNOUNCEMENT
OF THE PROPOSED RESTORATION OF
BUDGET GIVES US ALL HOPE WE CAN
MOVE FORWARD WITH NEW
INNOVATION TO BETTER SERVE THE
PUBLIC. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND FOR THE PROPOSED BUDGET
THANK YOU. AND THEN- JUDGE
PRIMARY IS ALSO ON THE LINE
JUST HUNDRED DID YOU. TO
PROVIDE A JUDICIAL AUTHORITY
FOR. ON PANDEMIC. CERTAINLY I
JUST HAVE A FEW COMMENTS- AS WE
PRESIDING JUDGES ON FOR SOMEONE
TO SAY YOU MADAM MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE I AM A JEW HEINRICH I
AM I IN HUMBOLDT ON THE JUDGE
THERE I'M CHAIR OF THE TRIAL
COURT- RESIDING ADVISORY AND
I'M ALSO IN ADVISORY OF THE
COUNT- I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
OPPORTUNITY ALLOW TO SPEAK- THE
COMMENT I WAS GONNA MAKE WHEN
HE TO MISS EVERHART A IS THAT
PROVIDING RELY A LOT OBVIOUSLY
ON THE- IS OFFICERS TO DO THE
BOTH OF THAT DAY TODAY.
ADMINISTRATION OF COURT JUDGES
I WANT ADD ALSO WORKED HARD THE
PAN AM LEARNING NEW TECHNIQUES
TO BE ABLE TO DO APPEARANCES UP
HITTING AS QUICKLY AS WERE ABLE
TO THERE'S A REAL- COURT IS-
CONSIDER A SMALL MEDIUM- AND
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN WE- EVEN
HOLD A COURT OPEN BECAUSE THE
NUMBER OF STAFF IT'S GOING TO-
IN MATTERS WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY
IN THE TO GET THINGS CA. AT THE
ONE THING THOUGH THAT WE HAVE-
HARD TO PROVIDE A TO WE- CAN DO
ALMOST ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO
IN THE PAST IT TAKES LONGER AND
WE HAVE TO BE MINDFUL OF THE
SAFETY OF OUR PUBLIC AND OTHERS
AS. WELL- WE ARE. WHAT
DILIGENTLY TO THOSE RELYING.
THAT TAKE PLACE. I COURSE WERE
A TO. GEAR UP AT THE RATES
BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY MAY
ALREADY HAD IN PLACE- BUT ALL.
A TO DO A NUMBER OF THINGS
REMOTELY. I THINK THE BACKLOG
THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE FACING
IS A HARD TO KEEP. EXACTLY AND
I ON. OUR BECAUSE OF FOR
EXAMPLE THE CHIEF JUSTICES- A
PUSH TO DEAL WITH CRIMINAL
BACKLOG IS GOING TO BE OF
ASSISTANCE S IT AT WE CAN GET
IN. AND IN PLACE- CIVIL BACKLOG
WERE ABLE TO DO A OF SAID.
MATTERS REMOTE HOWEVER CIVIL
JURY TRIALS OBVIOUSLY HAVE- ARE
AFTER CRIMINAL JURY TRIALS AND
THEY TAKE MUCH LONGER. TO DO.
IN ADDITION- PART OF WHAT I
THINK THE CHIEFS EFFORT OF
HAVING SETTLEMENT I'M MORE
INTENSE SETTLEMENTS IS IT
OFTENTIMES JURY TRIALS DON'T
SETTLE UNTIL THEY KNOW THERE'S
A JURY TRIAL AND THEN IT WE ARE
SCHEDULED. AND WE OBVIOUSLY
CAN'T DO THAT IN OUR CURRENT
SITUATION- AND THOUGH WE HAVE
FOUND- THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF MATTERS THAT CAN BE HELD
REMOTELY I THINK THAT WE- ARE
LOOKING AT HOW WE CAN BETTER
SERVE THE PUBLIC. AT EITHER
CONTINUE REMOTELY OR IN SOME
HYBRID MANNER AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY LOOKING AT WHAT IS
MOST. CRITICAL TO HAVE FOLKS IN
THE COURT ROOM. AND WHAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO. SO UNLESS
THERE ARE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS I
JUST WANT TO REITERATE THE
COMMENTS THAT- MR YOUNG AND MR
EVERHART MADE AND THAT. WE ARE
WORKING DILIGENTLY EVERY DAY
TO- TRY TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND FAIRNESS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- YOU WILL LOVE
THIS FINANCE WANT TO MAKE ANY
COMMENTS. ZERO NINE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I JUST WANT TO
PROVIDE AN UPDATE ON E. THIRTY
FUNDING THE TRIAL TO PROCESS
UNLAWFUL TO. YOU THE PASSAGE OF
NINETY ONE REAR WITH STRONGER.
FOR EIGHTY EIGHT PRIMARILY
ACTION INSTEAD BE WORK WITH
THAT YOU CAL. OVER THE COMING
IT'S THE OF ASKING NINE ONE ON
THE TRAVEL IN POTENTIALLY SOME
APPLY PRICKLES FOR BY RESOURCES
LATER THIS SPRING. AS FOR THE
JUDICIAL GENERAL FUND
RESTORATION THE IMMEDIATE ACT
PACKAGING AN AGREEMENT TO READ
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
UNDER RIGHT BACK. THE JUDICIAL
STYLE INCLUDE IN THE TWO BUDGET.
SPECIFIC THAT SPECIFICALLY ON
SEVENTY POINT NINE MILLION WILL
RESTORED THE TRIAL. IN TWENTY
THREE POINT ONE MILLION WILL BE
RESTORED TO THE STATE WOULD YOU
SAY BEGIN IN TWENTY TWENTY.
TWENTY TWO IN OUR GOING THE
USUAL IN USED. FUNDS TO ME
THEIR CHANGING OPERATION AND
PROGRAM. ANALYSTS ACCESS- SO WE
HAVE SOME OVER ARCHING COMMENTS
THAT WOULD APPLY TO THIS ISSUE
I AM AS WELL AS- THE- RATIONS
OF THE OTHER ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA. AND SIMPLE FOR YOU YOU
REALLY HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITIES FOR TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS WHICH MIGHT NOT BE
THE SAME AS A LEGISLATURE IS
AND SO WE REALLY ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT THE
TRIAL COURT FUNDING LEVELS AND
ALLOCATIONS. REALLY ALIGNED
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES FOR
THE LEVELS OF SERVICES AND
DESIRES WHICH CAN INCLUDE
EXPECTATIONS ABOUT COST
EFFECTIVENESS OR ACCEPTABLE
LENGTH OF DELAYS AS WELL AS
EQUITY. AND SO WHEN ENSURING
THAT THESE FUNDING LEVELS AND
SERVICE LEVELS MATCH THE
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER HOW MUCH ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO PROVIDE JUST
GENERALLY RELATIVE TO ITS OTHER
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES AND THE
STATE'S OVERALL PHYSICAL
CONDITION. AS WELL AS HOW THE
FUNDING SHOULD BE ALLOCATED AND
HOW MUCH DISCRETION TO PROVIDE
THE TRIAL COURTS OVER THE USE
OF THE FUNDING SO TO GIVE YOU A
REALLY QUICK EXAMPLE IF THE
LEGISLATURE BELIEVES AT THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY IS TO PREVENT
FURTHER REDUCTIONS IN SERVICE
LEVELS ARE GROSSLY PADLOCK- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REDIRECT ON A
ONE TIME OR ONGOING BASIS SOME
OF THE MONEY THAT. IS BEING
PROPOSED FOR SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
THAT WILL BE CONSIDERING LATER
TODAY. OR BECAUSE SATISFIED
FUNDING STORE FOR SPECIFIC
PURPOSES SUCH AS TO ADDRESS
PANDEMIC RELATED IMPACTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S BEING USED.
FOR THAT PURPOSE I THINK LAKE-
IN LINE WITH THAT THERE THEY'RE
KIND OF. THINGS THAT WE ARE
WANTED TO FOR ALEXIS
CONSIDERATION- AS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE REFERENCED- JUST
YESTERDAY A COUPLE DAYS AGO
THERE'S A THERE'S A PROPOSAL
FOR TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH RESTORING A REDUCTION
THAT WAS INCLUDED AS PART OF
THE TWENTY TWENTY BUDGET. AND
SO F YOU LOOK ON PAGE THREE OF
YOUR AGENDA JANUARY BUDGET
INCLUDED SEVENTY TWO POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING GENERAL CLASS.
THAT RESTORATION IS APPROVED AT
SEVENTY TWO POINT TWO MILLION
WOULD BE ON TOP OF THAT AND
SHOULD HAVE AN IMPACT ON- IN
IMPROVING SERVICE LEVELS. AND
THAT THAT RESTORATION IS NOT
APPROVED AND IT'S JUST A
SEVENTY TWO POINT TWO MILLION
WE WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT JUST THAT MONEY WOULD NOT
LIKELY. IMPACT SERVICE LEVELS
SUBSTANTIALLY AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS THAT IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET. USUAL BRANCH THE
TRIAL COURT SPECIFICALLY
RECEIVED A ONE TIME FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR OFFSET AND WITH
THAT EXPLORATION IN THE BUDGET
YEAR OF THE TRIAL COURTS WOULD
HAVE HAD TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
ACTION TO IMPLEMENT IT. AS A
LARGE SHARE OF THE SEVENTY TWO
POINT TWO MILLION WOULD LIKELY
HAVE GONE TO AVOID FURTHER
REDUCTIONS IN SERVICES. AND
AGAIN THIS IS ABSENCE YOU KNOW
THAT TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION THAT WAS RECENTLY AT
RETAIL- THE SECOND THAT WE
WANTED TO FIND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER TO CHANGE
STATE LAW. TO PROVIDE ONGOING
AUTHORIZATION FOR CERTAIN
OPERATIONAL IMPROVEMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED BY THE
TRIAL COURT'S DURING THE
PANDEMIC THEY'RE CURRENTLY-
DOING SOME OF THESE UNDER
EMERGENCY AUTHORIZATION- FOR
EXAMPLE THE USE OF VIDEO
CONFERENCING TECHNOLOGY. AND
SOME OF THESE THINGS CAN HAVE-
YOU KNOW CAN HELP THE COURTS
OPERATE MORE COST EFFECTIVELY
BUT ALSO INCREASE ACCESS TO
COURT SERVICES AND SO THE%
LEGISLATION MIGHT WANT TO
CONTINUE. MIGHT WANT TO DESIRE
TO MAINTAIN THEM. AND THE THIRD
AND FINAL THING OF THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH TALKED A LOT ABOUT KIND
OF THE INCREASED COSTS AND
IMPACTS RELATED TO THE
PANDEMIC. THE THING THAT WE DID
ONE OF LACK OF THE LEGISLATURE
IS AT THE TOP THE IMPACT OF THE
PANDEMIC ARE LIKELY TO IMPACT
SERVICE LEVELS. EVEN BEYOND THE
BUDGET YEAR DESPITE EFFORTS TO
KIND OF MINUTE MITIGATE OR OR
MINIMIZE THEM. SO FOR EXAMPLE
ON THE JURY TRIALS YOU'RE
LIKELY TO STILL HAVE BACKLOGS
IN THOSE AREAS AS WE ARE TRYING
TO CONDUCT THEM IN A SAFE
PUBLICLY YOU KNOW PUBLIC
HEALTH- PERMISSIBLE MANNER. AND
UNCLEAR HOW LONG IT WOULD TAKE
FOR US TO RETURN TO NORMAL
PROCESSING TIMES AS OF THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY TO PREVENT. OR
MINIMIZE THOSE LONGER TERM
IMPACTS SUCH AS PROVIDING
FUNDING SPECIFICALLY FOR
ADDITIONAL SPACE OR STAFF TO
CONDUCT JURY TRIALS IN A SAFE
MANNER SO THOSE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT WE WILL OFFER TO THE
LEGISLATURE. FOR KIND OF THEIR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS-
ABOUT ONE WOULD BE WHAT WOULD
BE. I DON'T MEAN PIE IN THE SKY
BUT WHAT WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE AMOUNT TO RESTORE
COURT OPERATIONS TO PREPEND THE
MAKE LEVELS AND WHAT ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT AREAS OF NEED. I
DON'T KNOW IF THE- MISTER YOUNG
YEAH SO THIS IS THE ROBERT A
YOUNG I AM I CAN ANSWER THAT IN
TERMS OF- RESTORATION- I THINK
THAT CHIEF JUSTICE REALLY
SUPPORTS PRIOR BUDGET CUT
RESTORATION- SHOULD THE STATE
REVENUES CONDITIONS IMPROVED-
IN TERMS OF. THE PRIORITIES THE
COURTS HAVE REALLY TAKEN AN
INDIVIDUAL SPECIFIC ACTIONS.
DUE TO THE PANDEMIC THAT HAVE
AFFECTED THEM LOCALLY SO IN
SOME CASES SOME COURTS HAVE HAD
TO REDUCE OUR STAFFING SOME
HAVE HAD TO HAVE- FURLOUGHS
OTHERS HAVE DELAYED-
INVESTMENTS IN ADDITIONAL
SERVICES AND SO THERE IS NOT
ONE PARTICULAR AREA OF PRIORITY
WHERE THE MONEY WOULD BE SPENT
IT'S REALLY DEPENDENTUPON EACH
INDIVIDUAL COURT IN TERMS OF
HOW THEY ADJUSTED AND PIVOTED.
TO ADDRESS THEIR LOCAL
CONSTRAINTS ARE IN THEIR COUNTY
AND SO THAT WOULD BE A
COMBINATION OF OUR STAFFING AS
WELL AS ADDITIONAL SERVICES AND
INVESTMENTS. HI NANCY I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAVE ANY OTHER
ADDITIONS YOU'D LIKE TO-
BATTERED WE'RE JUST TRYING TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- I WOULD
AGREE WITH MR YOUNG OF MANY
COURTS HAVE TO REDUCE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS DEPENDING ON- IF
THEY HAD A TWO OR 3% RESERVE
AVAILABLE TO. KIND OF PRESENT A
GLIDE PATH- MANY COURTS HAVE TO
FURLOUGH OR LAYOFFS OR CREATE
THEY CAN SEIZE AND ALSO DIFFER
MANY PROJECTS- SO THAT WOULD BE
A PRIORITIZATION TO GET US BACK
TO PRE COATED. TIMES SO THERE
AREN'T ANY PARTICULAR UNIVERSAL-
ACROSS THE BOARD- AREAS OF NEED.
OUR LIST OF THE LOCAL
CONDITIONS OR IN ADDITION TO
THE LOCAL CONDITIONS MADAM
CHAIR- A COMMON THEME IS
REDUCTION IN STAFFING. AND- AND
FURLOUGHS. BUT NOT IN A
PARTICULAR SERVICE. NOT IN A
PARTICULAR AREA I'M PARTICULAR-
THE WITH REGARD TO THE BACKLOG
BACKLOG- DO YOU HAVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT SO WE
COULD UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT OF
THE ISSUE. SO IN TERMS OF THE
BACKLOGS- BACKLOG CAN BE
MEASURED IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT
WAYS R. AND WHEN THE- JUDICIAL
OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
HELP- ALLEVIATE THE BACKLOGS
THE TRIAL COURT BUDGET ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AS WELL AS THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH BUDGET-
COMMITTEE. ARM CAME TOGETHER TO
TRY TO COME UP WITH A MODEL FOR
QUANTIFYING BACKLOGS ACROSS THE
BRANCH AND SO WHAT THEY DID.
WAS THEY LOOKED AT THE CHANGE
IN THE NUMBER OF DISPOSITIONS
BETWEEN PRE VET PANDEMIC TIMES
TO PANDEMIC ARE. AND WHAT THEY
DID- NOTICED- PLEASE FROM THE
COLLECTION OF THE DATE OF
DISPOSITION- WE FALL THAT ON
AVERAGE- COURTS EXPERIENCED A
REDUCTION IN ABOUT 45% ARE IN
THE NUMBER OF DISPOSITIONS THAT
THEY WERE- ABLE TO PROCESS-
DURING THE PANDEMIC- THAT ALSO
IS REFLECTIVE OF- NEED THAT
ALSO YOU NEED TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. DURING THAT
TIME- THE NUMBER OF FILINGS-
HAVE REDUCED AS WELL- HOWEVER
THE ACTUAL NUMBER OF
DISPOSITIONS IN TERMS OF THE
AGAIN THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF
DISPOSITION BEING PROCESS
REDUCED BY ABOUT FRTY FIVE
PERCENT- AVERAGE NUMBER OF
FILINGS REDUCE DURING THAT
PANDEMIC TIME- RANGED ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY ON AVERAGE AGAIN
THAT WAS ANYWHERE BETWEEN
ABOUT. 20% OR SO- SO THAT WAS
YOU KNOW THIS NEXT REDUCTION IN
THE NUMBER OF DISPOSITIONS ARE
THAT THE COURTS COULD PROCESS
AND THAT WAS USED AS A PROXY
FOR MEASURING- THE BACKLOG IN
VARIOUS AREAS. OKAY- THAT'S IT
FOR ME I'M SORRY I DIDN'T M.
WELCOME CENTER GROVE TO THE
COMMITTEE. GREAT TO HAVE YOU
HERE- ALEX ANY QUESTIONS FOR ME
ALL. YEAH OKAY SIR CRITICIZING.
OKAY IN THE CENTER GROVE. I
THANK YOU VERYMUCH OF FOR.
REVIEW OVERVIEW- APOLOGIZE FOR
COMING IN JUST A COUPLE MINUTES
LATER THINK- FOR THE OVERALL
PRESENTATION- DUE TO SOMETHING
ELSE GOING ON- FOR ME BUT THAT
DOES SAID I HAVE- A COLUMN IN A
SPECIFIC QUESTION ON ONE OF THE
ITEMS A COMMENT IS. IS JUST
THAT IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
HEARING THIS OVERVIEW- POORLY
IN IN CERTAINLY I'VE MY STAFF
AND I HAVE A BROKEN DOWN
TODAY'S PACKET BUT GOING
FORWARD TO TRY TO. ALMOST
CREATED A CHART OR SPREADSHEET
THAT DEALS WITH THE ANSWERS TO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS- SO WHAT
YOU JUST ASKED MADAM CHAIR IN
THANK YOU- WITH REGARD TO IN IN
SOME OF WHAT WE JUST HEARD
FROM. THE LAST TESTIMONY- WHAT
WHAT IS- BASELINE TO WHAT DOES
IT TAKE TO BRING JUST BASELINE
ONGOING FUNDING BACK WHAT DOES
IT TAKE TO DEAL WITH THE ONE
TIME THAT WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE
L. L. A. O.'S OFFICE AND I MADE
MY OWN NOTES BUT THAT THAT'S
THAT'S IN AND OF ITSELF- SORT
OF A DEBIT AND A CREDIT SO TO
SPEAK THAT NEEDS TO BE
ACCOUNTED FOR GOING FORWARD I
THINK. AND THEN AND THEN
THERE'S IN MY MIND- BACKLOG
ISSUES WHICH- WE ARE SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN ONE TIME AND ONGOING I
MEAN IN THE SENSE YOU DON'T
WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
BACKLOG THEN FALL BACK AGAIN
BUT. YOU KNOW LADIES. IT STANDS
TO REASON THAT IF YOU TAKE IF
YOU INVESTIGATING THE BACKLOG
CAUGHT UP THE NEW AT SOME POINT
YOU CAN RETURN BACK TO BASELINE
FUNDING GOING FORWARD AND I
JUST THINK THOSE ARE DIFFERENT
CATEGORIES. THAT IT WOULD HELP
ME MAYBE I'M JUST A VISUAL
PERSON TO JUST SEE THOSE
CHARTED OUT- MUCH MUCH LIKE
THE- THE SPEAKERS WERE WERE
TRYING TO. I THINK WORLEY
CONCERT THRILLED THAT OUT FOR
US TODAY MY SPECIFIC QUESTION.
HAS TO DO WITH IT ON PAGE THREE
ITEM THREE THE ELEVEN POINT
SEVEN. MILLION DOLLARS. A TO
PROTEST PROCESS ANTICIPATED
INCREASE UNLAWFUL DETAINER
SMALL CLAIMS FILINGS RESULT FOR
MAYBE THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT AND I
HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR AND IN I
KNEW BEFORE I CAME IN TODAY
THAT- FROM READING THE PACKAGE
THAT THAT WAS WITHDRAWN BY THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR RE
EVALUATION IN A TO- RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS ASSUME SB NINETY
ONE AND- THE EXTENSION. ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I'VE I'VE
SPOKEN OUT. A LITTLE BIT ON. IS
MY BELIEF THAT- IN ADDITION.
TO- ANTICIPATED INCREASE
INCREASES IN UT'S AT SOME POINT
WAS A MORATORIUM IS OVER THAT.
HE IN IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THAT
IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THE
ESSENTIALLY THE- WHAT COULD BE
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN CHAOS WERE
JUST. TRAUMA TO BOTH LANDLORDS
AND TENANTS SAID WE NEED SOME
SORT OF MEDIATION SERVICES- WE
NEED LEGAL AID SERVICES MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SPOKEN TO
THAT- IN IN BUDGET HEARINGS ARE
ON THE FOR THE SENATE- BUT
MEDIATION. SERVICES OR
AUGMENTATION TO EXISTING
SERVICES I KNOW THE COURTS- YOU
KNOW I GUESS DEPENDING ON ON
WHICH COUNTY PROVIDE THAT
INSTITUTIONALLY TO SOME EXTENT
IN AGAIN AS A FORMER COUNTY
SUPERVISOR I KNOW THAT SOME
COUNTIES LIKE SANTA CLARA- HAVE
THEIR OWN PROGRAMS IN SOME
CITIES LIKE SAN JOSE HAVE THEIR
OWN PROGRAMS. EITHER
SPECIFICALLY TO DEAL WITH
LANDLORD TENANT MEDIATION IN
HARDSHIP FOR. NEIGHBORHOOD
MEDIATION PROGRAMS LIKE IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY THAT ARE
SORT OF INTENDED TO HEAD OFF-
DISPUTES THAT MIGHT OTHER
OTHERWISE AND UP- IT IN THE
COURT SYSTEM. SO. I WOULD HAVE
WOULD HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
PROPOSE- IN CERTAINLY PASSES
ALONG TO THE ADMINISTRATION AS
WELL AS SOME SORT OF ADDITIONAL
BUG BUDGET AUGMENTATION IS TO
IS TO DEAL WITH THAT NOW- AS
SOON AS WE CAN IN ADVANCE OF
NOT ONLY TO ADVANCE OF THE
ALTAR EVENTUAL EXPIRATION OF
THE- OF THE MORATORIUM. BUT
ANTICIPATION OF THE ROLL OUT OF
FEDERAL AID IT IS GOING TO PUT
A LOT OF LANDLORDS AND TENANTS
I THINK IN A SITUATION OF.
PARTIAL SATISFACTION- IN I
DON'T KNOW IF- THE AGENTS ON
THE CALL WOULD AGREE- TODAY BUT
I THINK PARTIAL SATISFACTION IS
OFTEN- RECIPE FOR ONGOING
DISPUTES- THAT EITHER NEED TO
BE ADJUDICATOR MEDIA THAT SAID
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR BACK. ANY
RESPONSE TO THAT WE HAVE TIME
THIS THIS ITEM WILL BE HELD
OPEN SO I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR
ANYTHING THAT YOU MIGHT WANT TO
COMMENT ON TODAY IF I'M OFF OR
WRONG- I SHOULD PROBABLY HEAR
THAT TODAY THE PRETTY GREEN
TERMS OF. THE NEED FOR ANY ANY
AUGMENTATION OF MEDIATION
SERVICES SOON SOONER RATHER
THAN LATER WITH. YES OR NO ON
THAT IF THE ANSWER IS YES THEN-
I'LL JUST JUMP AHEAD AND SAID
LIKE TO MAKE SURE THAT- WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT TO FUTURE
COMMITTEE OPTIONS. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR YEAH THANK YOU AND
I DON'T KNOW ANY OF THE JUDGES
COULD RESPOND TO THAT PROBABLY
FIRSTHAND FROM THEIR
EXPERIENCE- WHERE THEY SAID BUT
ALSO I SUPPOSE FINANCE BUT ALL.
OF THE FOR THE US ADJOURNMENT.
BINANCE OKAY ONLY SIX REMINDS
REMINDS YES. HELLO AND I JUST
WANTED TO WRITE A BRIEF
BACKGROUND OF LEGAL AID
SERVICES CURRENTLY THERE ARE
TWO PARTS OF FUNDING AVAILABLE
FOR GRANTS THE LEGAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE LEGAL AID
SERVICES FOR RENTERS AND HOME
OWNERS THE FIRST IS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS PROVIDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT THE CENTER EXPECTED
ME SPENT BY THE END OF THE YEAR
THE SECOND PART OF FUNDING IS
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS WAS
INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET. THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL'S
IN PROCESS OF FINALIZING GRANT
AGREEMENT AND EXPECTS TO HAPPEN
SPEND ALLOCATED SERVICE
PROVIDERS THIS MONTH EVEN THAT
FUNDING IS JUST NOW GOING OUT
TO SERVICE PROVIDERS ADDITIONAL
FUNDING IS NOT BEING AT
ALLOCATED AT THIS TIME HOWEVER
TO THE EXTENT EDITION RESOURCES
ARE NEEDED AND JUNIORS WE CAN
ALWAYS CONSIDER PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THIS
PURPOSE- HOWEVER SPEAKING TO
THE PROGRAMMATIC IMPACT ON
CAPITAL FOR TO THE JUDICIAL-COUNCIL WHERE THEY CAN PROVIDE
MORE INFORMATION ON. YOUR
QUESTION IS HOW IT RELATES. TO
THE MEDIATION IT CAN I JUST IT
BEFORE WE- THE LOSES SPEAKERS I
MAY NOT. HERE TO THIS IDOL ITS
BUSINESS AMMAN IS A YOUR NAME-
ANYWAY LET ME JUST. IF WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING IS WHEN I SPEAK
TO MEDIATION SERVICES THAT IS.
IT WILL BE YOUR UNDERSTANDING
THAT. A GRANT ELIGIBILITY WOULD
INCLUDE NOT JUST LEGAL
ASSISTANCE TO TENANTS- SO THEY
HAVE AFFECTED ASSISTANCE FOR
COUNCIL BUT ALSO MEDIATION
SERVICES CAN COME FROM ONE OF
THOSE TWO PARTS ARE BOTH. IT'S
BEEN TRYING TO GET AN ANSWER TO
FOR A FEW WEEKS NOW. STARTING
IN OUR DISTRICT- THIS WOULD
INCLUDE MEDIATION SERVICES
ABOUT HAPPINESS FOR THE FUTURE
COUNCIL TO SPEAK UP SPEAK MORE
CLEARLY TO TWO YEAR SESSION MY
APOLOGIES NO PROBLEM THANK YOU.
OKAY CENTER GROVE. THANK YOU
MADAMCHAIR YEAH I'M SORRY WHAT
IS- OKAY I'M SORRY AM I GONNA
GET USED TO THIS- YES MISTER T.
V- DROVE IT. YES I WANNA LET
YOU KNOW THAT WE DO HAVE
PROGRAM EXPERTS- CHARLIE
INDUCTOR IN MONEY HOUSE WHO CAN
EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE
RESPOND TO SENATORS QUESTIONS
REGARDING THE CURRENT USAGE OF
FUNDS AND HOW THEY'RE
ALLOCATED- TO PROVIDE THE
SUPPORT AND SELF AND IF YOU
HAVE THOSE THOSE QUESTIONS
DEFINITELY HOUSE. MISTER HERE
AND HEALTH. PROVIDE THAT INPUT.
OKAY SO. SHOULD WE DO THAT AT A
FUTURE. TO DO THAT AT A FUTURE
HEARING OR DO WE WANT TO. GET
SOME OF THAT MEASURE- AND NO I
KNOW THE SPEED ONGOING
DISCUSSION I WOULD BE SATISFIED
IF. OF REPRESENTATIVES THAT
WERE JUST IDENTIFIED COULD
REACH OUT TO THE COMMITTEE
OFFICES ARE THE TO OUR OFFICES-
DEPENDING ON- MY COLLEAGUES
METER APPETITE FOR THAT
INFORMATION I KNOW I KNOW WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION AND- IN
SPECIFICALLY IN IN CASE THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO. AT
SOME POINT BEFORE THE END OF
THIS CRISIS- A SUGGESTS
AUGMENTATION OR SUGGEST ANY
KIND OF CLARITY OR
CLARIFICATION ON- MAKING THAT
GRANT PROGRAM- APPROPRIATELY
SIZED- MAKING SURE IT IS
ALREADY SO I MAYBE WE CAN HELD
THAT WAY SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE
TO TIE EVERYONE UP WITH. THE
ANSWER MY QUESTION BUT RIGHT
BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE EVERYONE
ON THE COMMITTEE HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THOSE
QUESTIONS ANSWERED- OKAY THANK
WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH THAT.
CENTER GROVE. I'M THINKING
MADAM CHAIR IT'S DEFINITELY
PLEASURE TO JOIN YOU THIS IS MY
FIRST COMMITTEE AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY- I
DID WALK IN A LITTLE BIT LATE I
DO APOLOGIZE AND I WAS AND
LISTENING TO WHAT WAS PRESENTED
ON THE OVERALL VIEW AND- I MAY
HAVE MISUNDERSTOOD THE ANSWER
TO THAT SHARES QUESTION I HAD
THE SAME KIND OF QUESTION- I'LL
JUST REPEAT WHICH HE SAID NOT
PIE IN THE SKY BET- WHAT IS THE
ESTIMATED DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT
THE COURT AND THE- BRANCH SEES
IT WILL BE- FIT TO RESTORE
COURTS. TO WHERE THEY WERE PRE
PANDEMIC I DO KNOW THAT THERE'S
A TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR-
BUDGET REQUEST AFTER THE
RESTORATION WHAT WAS TAKEN
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC AND SO
I'M JUST CURIOUS IS THAT
SUFFICIENT OR EXERT MORE IN
THAT ASK AND OR IS IT
SUFFICIENT OR DO YOU FIND AT
THE BRANCH AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS AND LOCALS A STILL
FEEL SHORT CHANGED. WALKER
WOULD YOU WANT TO ADDRESS THAT.
CERTAINLY NO- WE DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THAT THE RESTORATION
AND FEEL THAT THAT IS THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL INVESTMENT AT
THIS TIME AS WE ARE EVALUATING
IN GOING FORWARD I THINK THE
MESSAGE THAT'S BEEN- YOU KNOW
DELIVERED ALONG WITH THE
RESTORATION IS THE NOTION THAT
THE TRUCKS WERE USING- THE
LESSONS LEARNED FROM THE
PANDEMIC IT IMPLEMENTED A
NUMBER OF CHANGES IN THE
PROCEDURES- TO FACILITATE AS
MANY TRANS. MANY AT PORT
OPERATIONS AS POSSIBLE AND ALSO
THE- THERE'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE JUST BEEN RELEASED-
YESTERDAY AND SPEAKS TO- THE
USE OF TECHNOLOGY IN THE
SEVERAL AND PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITIES THERE SO WE THINK
AS WE LOOK FORWARD TO OBVIOUSLY
BE EVALUATING THE WATER NEEDS
ARE BUT AS FAR AS THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL AND THE ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. WE
THINK THAT THAT IS A IS AN
EXCELLENT INVESTMENT FOR
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT ON. IN THE
BUDGET. GOING FORWARD. SO A
JUST TOOK A THAT THE THINGS
THAT EVEN LIKE THE U. OF TECH.
AND VIDEO CONFERENCING AND THE
ASSISTANT- I GUESS WE'D COLUMN
KIOSK IS PRETTY SIMPLE THE SELF
HELP ASSISTED KIOSK TYPE OF.
FACILITIES THAT WE'VE MADE
AVAILABLE ON THE COURT TO HELP
OTHERS IT STREAMLINED THE COURT
PROCESS. SO I'M JUST TRYING TO-
CONFIRM THAT THE TUNER MILLION
DOLLAR RESTORATION WAS TAKEN
YOU KNOW IN PRIOR YEARS IT ONCE
IT'S RESTORED DO YOU THINK THAT
ADDRESSES THE BACKLOG OF WORK
AS WELL OR IS THAT A SEPARATE
ISSUE. I WOULD DISCARDED TURNED
TO STRUGGLE IN TERMS OF- THE
OPERATIONAL. CHALLENGES AND THE
OPPORTUNITY BUT AGAIN. WAS WAS
SUPPORT OF THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION THE MIX OF SIGNIFICANT.
IMPROVEMENT IN THE OPERATION
WHAT'S- THANK YOU SIR. YEAH I
THINK THAT AS YOUNG- MS EVER
HARD HAD HAD MENTIONED- THAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME
TO. RESTORE BACK TO NORMAL I
THINK THAT THE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION IS REALLY GOING TO HELP
ESPECIALLY AS AGAIN AS EVERHART
HAD MENTIONED THERE IS A-
SEVERE- LACK OF RESOURCES I
THINK THAT WILL HELP US MOVE
FORWARD. THE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES THAT WE I HAVE
IMPLEMENTED WE DON'T ACTUALLY
SEE THAT REPLACING- SERVICES
GOING FORWARD WE ACTUALLY SEE
THAT- AS A ADDITIONAL. ABILITY
TO PROVIDE MORE SERVICE TO THE
PUBLIC AND SO WE SEE THAT THE
THINGS THAT WE HAVE PUT IN
PLACE IN TERMS OF REMOTE
SERVICES SOME OF THE KIOSK. WE
THINK THAT PEOPLE WILL CONTINUE
TO WANT TO DO BUSINESS WITH THE
COURTS IN THAT MANNER AND SO
THOSE WILL NEED TO CONTINUE
FORWARD AND AGAIN THE
RESTORATION OF THE MONEY WILL
WILL DEFINITELY HELP- WITH THE
BACKLOGS BUT WE WOULD NEED TO-
SEE THE PROGRESS AS WE-
IMPLEMENT THOSE CHANGES OVER
TIME. THANK YOU SIR I I'D LIKE
TO MOVE THE ITEMS. WE'RE NOT
LOADING TODAY SENATOR GROVE-
THESE ARE BEING HELD OPEN. SO
TO DATE NONE OF THESE ITEMS
WILL BE VOTED ON. HOLDING THEM
OPEN. WE ANNOUNCES THANK YOU
THANK YOU OKAY- IN NOTHING
NOTHING ELSE OKAY SO THIS IS A
HOLD OPEN LET'S MOVE ON TO
ISSUE TO A CONTINUATION OF SELF
HELP CENTERS AND TRIAL COURT-
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH PLEASE. YES
SIR MADAM CHAIR AND JUSTIN
BRIEFS- IN THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR THERE WAS
A NINETEEN POINT ONE MILLION
ONE MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
THE MUCH NEEDED SELF HELP
CENTER FUNDING THAT WAS
APPROVED ON A THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM BASIS BUDGET IS
NOT PROPOSING TO CONTINUE THAT
FUNDING I'M ON AN ONGOING
BASIS. TO MAINTAIN VITAL SOUTH
OF SERVICES TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF ACCESS FOR LITIGANTS
YEAH I HAVE ATTORNEYS TO HELP
THEM WITH HOUSING NOTHING
VIOLENCE FAMILY LAW CHILD
SUPPORT CONSUMER DEBT AND
SIMILAR ISSUES ALL OF WHICH ARE
EXACERBATED BY THE PANDEMIC- WE
DO HAVE AGAIN THE- CHARLENE
DOCTOR AND BONNIE HOUSE WHO ARE
ABLE TO DISCUSS THE ISSUE IN
ONE OR MORE INDEFINITELY AND
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. ABOUT THE- PROPOSED
ONGOING FUNDING ON AT THE
CURRENT. LEVELS THAT ARE IN THE
BUDGET. OKAY SO- WILL FINANCE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. YES YOU KNOW
MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS A FEW LA
US CONCERNS FOR THIS PROPOSAL
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE IT IS
IMPORTANT TO MAINTAIN ITS
INVESTMENT- SELF HELP CENTERS
BEYOND THAT YOU YEARS. AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE L. A. L.
BECAUSE THERE'S AN ONGOING
WORKLOAD FOR SOFTBALL TENNIS TO
ADDRESS ANOTHER COST BENEFIT
STUDY MAKE IT BENEFICIAL TO
ASSESS THE MONETARY VALUE OF
SEXUAL HEALTH SERVICES WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT THESE
RESOURCES SUPPORT THE
ASSISTANCE OF OVER ONE MILLION
SELF REPRESENTED INDIVIDUALS A
YEAR SO I'M GOING TO ONGOING
FUNDING WOULD BE IS NECESSARY.
WITHOUT SOMETHING WE CONTINUED
ONGOING TRIAL COURTS MAY BE
FORCED TO REDUCE SERVICE LEVELS
FOR CRITICAL SOME TOP ISSUES I
JUST CRITICAL HOUSING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE FAMILY WALL ON IT
OTHER ISSUES WHICH HAVE ONLY
ESCALATED SINCE THE ONSET OF
THE INTERNET. IN THE LONG TERM
IMPACT OF THE NINETEEN MAY
FURTHER INCREASE THE NEED FOR
SELF HELP CENTERS BEYOND THE
CHEERS IN ADDITION TO THE
EXTENT VISUAL CONTACT IS
REQUIRED TO COMPLETE A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS AS RECOMMENDED
BY THE L. A. L. YOU KNOW THAT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
COMPLETE THE STUDY SINCE THIS
WOULD BE. A NEW WORK WELL FOR
THEM TO ADDRESS. THANK YOU
MISTER- L. PLEASE. ANY DALY THE
WITH THE A. L. SO WE HAVE THREE
RECOMMEND ON THIS I- SO. WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE ADOPT BUDGET
TRAILER LEGISLATION DIRECTING
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO CONTRACT
WITH AN EXTERNAL RESEARCHER TO
COMPLETE THE COSTBENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF THE LEGISLATURE
REQUESTED AS PART OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET AND I
WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR THE
LEGISLATURE ASKED FOR A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS- AS PART OF.
THE PACKAGE TO PROVIDE THE
FUNDING FOR- THREE YEARS- WE
WOULD ALSO RECOMMEND THAT THIS
EXTERNAL CONTRACTOR PROVIDE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW THE
FUNDING COULD BE ALLOCATED BY
DELIVERY METHOD AND CASE TYPE
TO MAXIMIZE THE BENEFITS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND TO
THE COURT. THE REPORT THAT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH SUBMITTED
EARLIER THIS MONTH HOW DO A LOT
OF HELPFUL INFORMATION AND
INCLUDED- EXTENSIVE STAFF
EFFORT AND COLLECTED OUTCOME
DATA BUT IT IS MISSING THE KEY
PIECES OF A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS WHICH IS CALCULATING
THE MONETARY VALUE OF THE
IDENTIFIED BENEFITS IDENTIFYING
THE CORRESPONDING COSTS AND
IDENTIFYING THE NET BENEFIT OF
THE VARIOUS SELF HELP DELIVERY
METHODS- AND SO WE VIEW OUR
RECOMMENDATION AS- COMPLETING
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE PREVIOUSLY
REQUESTED AND WITHOUT THIS
INFORMATION IT'S REALLY
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
TO DETERMINE WHAT LEVEL OF
FUNDING IS WARRANTED AND HOW
THAT FUNDING SHOULD BE USED TO
MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT WHAT DO WE
DO RECOMMEND THAT THAT REPORT%
BE SUBMITTED NO LATER THAN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY IN
ORDER TO INFORM LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET DECISIONS AND TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR. OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION IN LINE WITH
THIS YOU DATE IS THAT WE DO
RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE ONLY
PROVIDE THE REQUESTED FUNDING
FOR AN ADDITIONAL TWO YEARS
THIS. PREVENTS THE REDUCTION IN
SERVICE AND HELPS MAINTAIN ALL
OF THE EQUITY RELATED BENEFITS
THAT COMES FROM THESE RESOURCES
BUT THAT IS UNTIL THE
LEGISLATURE RECEIVES THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS. TO THEN
INFORM THEIR JUST ASIANS MOVING.
AND SO THAT IS HOW THE ALLOW.
AND THE INFORMATION WILL WOULD
BE HELPFUL. OUR LAST
RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT. EXCUSE ME
THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER ADOPTING PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE TO SPECIFY ITS
PRIORITIES FOR THE USE OF THE
SELF HELP CENTER FUNDING. SO
FOR EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE
COULD CONSIDER SPECIFYING THAT
A MINIMUM AMOUNT OF THE MONEY
SHOULD BE USED TO PROVIDE
SERVICES REMOTELY SO CURRENTLY
WE HEARD FROM THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH THAT'S AWFUL SERVICES
ARE BEING PROVIDED REMOTELY-
BECAUSE- ACCESS TO THE COURT
HOUSES ARE RESTRICTED. BUT THIS
COULD ACTUALLY HAVE BENEFIT
JUST ON AN ONGOING BASIS- UNDER
NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES FOR
EXAMPLE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
MIGHT HAVE TO TRAVEL FAR
DISTANCES TO KIND OF VISIT THE
COURTS TO RECEIVE. THESE
SERVICES OTHERWISE IN THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WANT TO PRIORITIZE USES OF
THESE DOLLARS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE- SELF HELP
CENTERS- OF THE HOW WITH A SELF
HELP CENTERS ADDRESSING THE
DEMAND FOR SERVICES FROM.
LITIGANTS LIVING IN AREAS WITH
LIMITED INTERNET ACCESS. AND
OR- WAR NOT LITERATE IN
TECHNOLOGY- I'M HAPPY TO
ADDRESS THAT- I AM A BONNIE
HUFF AND I WORK FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND THE HONOR
TO WORK- ON THE SPACIOUS-
CENTERS TO THIS IN A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT WAYS- FIRST OF ALL.
MANY OF THE REMOTE SERVICES ARE
OFFERED BY TELEPHONE WHICH MOST
PEOPLE DO HAVE ACCESS TO AND
SOME COURTS ARE USING TEXTING
EMAIL ANOTHER COMMON SERVICES.
BOB WELL AS WE'RE EXPANDING
INTO VIDEO CONFERENCING AND
OTHER WAYS TO ALLOW OF FOLKS TO
HAVE MORE OF A FACE TO FACE
COMMUNICATION WORK REVIEW
PAPERWORK THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS- FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE A-
A GROUP OF TWENTY TWO PORTS IN
THE ROLE COMMUNITIES. THAT HAVE
BANDED TOGETHER AND SO SOMEBODY
pCAN GO TO ONE OF THOSE SPORTS
AND BE CONNECTED WITH- A OF.
ANY ERA COURT WITHIN THAT- THAT
COMMUNITY OF FIVE. OF SERVICES-
THEN THAT ALLOWS FOR VIDEO
CONFERENCING. TECHNOLOGY ALL
KINDS OF SERVICE AS UP ANOTHER
UP ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS LOS
ANGELES WHERE THEY'RE OFFERING
WORKSHOPS BY WEBEX BUT IF A
LITIGANT DOES NOT HAVE THAT
TECHNOLOGY THEY CAN COME TO
COURT. AND WATCHING A WORKSHOP
ROOM. IN A SOCIALLY DISTANCE
MANNER. IN OTHER CIRCLE WITH
AGENCIES IN THERE CAN. TO SET
UP COMPUTERS IN PUBLIC PLACES
SUCH AS LIBRARIES AND COMMUNITY
CENTERS- THIS ALLOWS PEOPLE TO.
GET ACCESS FROM SELF HELP
CENTERS WITHOUT ME TO COURT AND
I DO THINK- AS AS MISLEAD
SUGGESTED I ABSOLUTELY THINK
THAT MANY OF THESE SERVICES ARE
GOING TO BE CONTINUING. I'M
PARTICULARLY FOR PEOPLE WHERE
THERE IS SOME REAL CHALLENGES
CONTESTANTS AND THESE ALL
STARTED BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
BUT- THOSE INVESTMENTS THAT
WORK THAT THE SELF HLP CENTERS
OF DOWN HAVE REALLY PAID OFF IN
MANY WAYS. TO ENABLE US TO
PROVIDE NEARLY THE SAME LEVEL
OF SERVICES THAT WE- EVEN BEAT
THAT WE. WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
EVEN BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. I AT
EXAM IN FRESNO THE COURT HAS
PLACED COMPUTERS AT LEAST
STATIONS DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SHELTER AND COMMUNITY AGENCIES
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTY. AND SO THAT ALLOWS THE
COURT BASED ATTORNEY NEEDS TO
HAVE VIDEO CONFERENCE MEETINGS
WITH LITIGANTS WHO HAVE COME TO
THE COURTHOUSE. AND ALLOWS THE
SELF HELP STAFF AND WOOD
AGAINST TO SEE THE SAME SCREEN.
SO THE SELF HELP CENTER CAN
HELP WITH AGAINST EMPLOYEE
PERFORMANCE. I'M OKAY WELL- I
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER- I STILL
THINK THAT THERE'S A AN ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO.
PAY A LOT OF ATTENTION TO- SOME
OF US HAVE BECOME SO. USED TO
HAVING THE TECHNOLOGY HAVING
THE DEVICES HAVING THE
CONNECTIVITY. THAT IT JUST
SEEMS SO SIMPLE- BUT IN REALITY
FOR THE COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE
SEEN THAT NOW WITH SCHOOLS
BEING CLOSED AND- ALL. WHO GETS
IMPACTED THE WORST BY THAT ARE-
POOR COMMUNITIES- COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR. THAT DON'T HAVE THAT
CONNECTIVITY EITHER THEY FOR
THE KIDS DON'T OR THE PARENTS
DON'T KNOW HOW TO HANDLE IT SO.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE SHOULD JUST JUMP ON AND
SAY. GREAT TECHNOLOGY MAKES IT
EASIER- AND IN SOME WAYS IS
GREAT UP BUT WE'RE STILL
LEAVING PEOPLE BEHIND AND- WE
SHOULD BE VERY. COGNIZANT OF
THAT. AND PUT THAT INFORMATION
ON THE TABLE AS MUCH AS ALL THE
GREAT THINGS THAT COME FROM
TECHNOLOGY. ABSOLUTELY I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU AND I
THINK MOVING FORWARD- THE IN
PERSON SERVICES ARE GOING TO BE
CRITICAL AND HAVING THE STAFF
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THAT IS
GOING TO BE CRITICAL. AS PART
OF A HYBRID YOU KNOW TRYING TO
TAKE THE BEST OF WHAT WE CAN
DO- FOR THOSE PEOPLE CAN USE
TECHNOLOGY. BUT ABSOLUTELY
BEING AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE IN
PERSON SERVICES IS ALSO REALLY
ESSENTIAL. YEP AND THEN JUST-
ONE MORE QUESTION HERE- IT WHAT
KINDS OF CASES IF YOU HAVE A
BREAKDOWN FROM THESE SELF HELP
CENTERS. AS TO THE KINDS OF
CASES. THAT ARE HANDLED- AND-
AND THAT SHOWS HOW MUCH OF
FUNDING WENT TO THE SELF HELP
SERVICES OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS. ACT ABOUT THE ABOUT 78%
OF THE CASES INVOLVE FAMILY
LAW. DIVORCE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
OUT OF CUSTODY AND SPORTAGE IS.
OF 18% I WENT TO THE CIVIL LAW
OF CASES THIS IS HOW. THE BIRDS.
WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE SERVICES
THAT SIX WAS A BIG INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF CIVIL CASES SO OF
LANDLORD TENANT AND SMALL
CLAIMS TO SERVE OUR FRESHMAN.
OF MANY OF THESE CASE TYPES
EFFECT WE- THAT WORKS INCREASED
SERVICES. SIGNIFICANTLY AND
LANDLORD TENANT CASES. OF IN
FACT THAT NUMBER WOULD BE ABLE
TO ASSIST PRIOR TO THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING THE HELP
CENTERS ASSISTED ABOUT 8% OF
THE CASES IN LANDLORD TENANT
MATTERS. PRESS THE BOARD AND
NOW OF A CENTERS ARE ASSISTING
IN 22% OF THE CASES THAT ARE
COMING BEFORE THE COURT AND
WHEN IT MATTERS. AGAIN I FANTA
THAT WILL INCREASE AGAIN WITH
THE YOUNG- AS THE MORATORIUM
WHAT AND THEN PROBATE WHICH IS
PRIMARILY- GUARDIANSHIP OF FIVE
CHILDREN THAT THE CARE OF AND A
CONSERVATORSHIP IS ABOUT 4% OF
THE SERVICES. AND IN TERMS OF
HOW THE FUNDING WHICH USED OF
THE VAST MAJORITY OF FUNDING
95% OF FUNDING IS USED FOR
STAFF AND SO THE NUMBER OF
STAFF THAT WERE ARE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE INCREASE
FROM A HUNDRED FIFTY SIX- FULL
TIME EQUIVALENTS TO THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX A QUICK WENT
FULL TIME EQUIVALENT STAFF OF
ATTORNEYS AND- NON ATTORNEY
PROFESSIONALS. AND 46% OF THOSE
NEW STAFF MEMBERS ARE BILINGUAL.
OKAY- THIRTY. AND THE SPEND-
THERE'S NINETEEN MILLION THAT
WILL BE GOING TO THE SELF HELP
CENTERS- DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA AS
TO HOW THOSE- THE DELIVERY
METHOD IT'S GOING TO BE USES IT
PERSON IN PERSON VIRTUAL.
HYBRID OF IN PERSON NUMBER JOEL.
I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
EVOLVING- JUST AS WE HAVE
CONTINUED TO EVOLVE I THINK AS
YOU POINTED OUT OF WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO HAVE IN PERSON
SERVICES THEY'RE JUST GOING TO
BE PEOPLE WHO REALLY NEED THAT-
BOTH BECAUSE OF TECHNOLOGY AND
THESE ARE LIFE CHANGING EVENTS
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES THAT THEY'RE
COMING TO WORK TO DEAL WITH THE
COMING FOR OBJECTION ARE COMING
FOR THE MASSIVE VIOLENCE
THEY'RE COMING FOR OTHER
THINGS. AND- FOR SOME FOLKS
THAT'S OKAY IN TECHNOLOGY OTHER
PEOPLE REALLY REALLY NEED MUCH
MORE ON PERSONAL SERVICE. AND
SO I THINK THAT AS I SAY I
THINK IT'S JUST GOING TO
CONTINUE TO EVOLVE THE COURTS
HAVE MADE ENORMOUS STRIDES. IN
TRYING TO IDENTIFY THE BEST
WAYS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION AND
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE DURING
THIS PERIOD. AND I DON'T THINK
WE KNOW THE RIGHT ANSWER YET-
THE DATA THAT WE HAD FOR THE
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS WAS FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN AND- EVERYTHING
CHANGED IN TERMS OF. OF HOW
PEOPLE ARE USING ASSISTANCE-
WHAT STATE AT ALL THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS SO- WE'RECONTINUING
TO EVOLVE AND GROW AND REALLY.
ENCOURAGE COURTS TO BE AS
INNOVATIVE AS POSSIBLE TO
PROVIDE THE BEST ASSISTANCE
POSSIBLE TO THE MOST AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE. AND WE NEED EVERY WEEK
NOW- WITH THE SELF HELP CENTER
STAFF IN A WEBEX MEETING AND
SUPPORT SHARE THEIR BEST
PRACTICES AND IDEAS- AND I
THINK WE'LL JUST REALLY NEED TO
CONTINUE TO SEE HOW THAT OF
ALL. I CERTAINLY DON'T FEEL
THAT I KNOW THE EXACT RIGHT
ANSWERS YET. OKAY THANK YOU.
POLITICS SENATOR NEWMAN. SO I'M
THIS CHECK AYE TO. IF I'M-
NAIVE OR UNINFORMED SO. ON OKAY.
QUESTION ABOUT THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS OF THE L. A. O.'S
COMMENTS INDICATE THAT THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS WAS
INCOMPLETE- AS REQUIRED BY THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET- BUT THAT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH SUBMITTED A REPORT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- TO COMPLY
BUT WHICH THE L. A- WOULD
ASSERT DID NOT SO WE WOULD- DID
DID FRANK IT'S A COURSE FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH FIRST- WOULD
YOU. DISAGREE WITH THE L. A.
O.'S CHARACTERIZATION. OF
HAVING FAILED TO DO THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS. I THINK THAT
WE ABSOLUTELY DID THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS I THINK THAT
THEY ARE- AS THEY SAY THAT
THERE WERE THINGS THAT WE HAD
HOPED TO COLLECT APPROACH YOU
HAVE A PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT WE SIMPLY
COULDN'T DO AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC. BUT I THINK THAT THE-
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS THAT WE
SUBMITTED IT PROVIDES EXTENSIVE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SORT OF
THE MIX OF DELIVERY SYSTEMS IN
WHERE WORKSHOPS CAN BE HELPFUL
WHERE THERE ARE CHALLENGES-
AND- HOW WHEN I WENT TO WORK-
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT TECHNOLOGY IT
HAS PROVIDED ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
DATA. AND IT ALSO- ADDRESSED
MANY OF THE ISSUES IN TERMS OF
JUDICIAL OFFICERS AND STAFF TO
TALK ABOUT HOW FILINGS ARE NOT
REJECTED- WHEN THEIR STUFF OF
STAFF- PERFORMS ARE ACTUALLY
LEGIBLE AND THEIR COMPLETE AND
HOW MUCH TIME THAT SAVES THAT
PARTIES UNDERSTAND THEIR CASES
BETTER THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
COME TO COURT WERE PREPARED.
AND THAT JUDGES AND COURT STAFF
AND ARE BETTER REVIEW DOCUMENTS.
IN IN MUCH LESS TIME. ALSO DOWN.
THE INCREASED MEDIA. FOR SELF
HELP US. TALK ABOUT THAT. JUST
OVER. SERVICES BEING PROVIDED-
AND- HOW MUCH MORE IS NEEDED
AND WE DID A- CUSTOMER
SATISFACTION. SURVEY IS PART OF
THAT RECEIVE NEARLY SEVEN
THOUSAND- RESPONSES AND WHILE
PEOPLE WERE THRILLED WITH THE
SERVICE LISTEN NUMBER NINETY
SIX PERCENT- WERE. EXTREMELY
SATISFIED OR VERY SATISFIED
AND- BUT THEY'RE THE KINDS OF
THINGS THEY TALKED ABOUT WHEN
WE ASKED YOU KNOW DO YOU HAVE
ANY SUGGESTIONS FOR
IMPROVEMENTS AND THEY TALKED
ABOUT WE NEED MORE STAFF-
REDUCE WAIT TIMES AND LINES
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS WE KNOW
THAT THERE IS. A VERY STRONGLY.
AND AGAIN I THINK THE KINDS OF
IN TERMS OF THE ALLOCATION
STRATEGY THAT I USE I. AM SURE
THAT THE L. A. O. WITH- YOU
KNOW WE ALL WANT TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES AS EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE. AGAIN I THINK THAT IN
TIME OF ENORMOUS. AND
DEVELOPMENT AND OF THOSE KINDS
OF THINGS BECOME EXT REALLY
DIFFICULT TO TELL AND- BOTH YOU
KNOW EVERYONE'S. ACCEPTANCE AND
ABILITY TO USE TECHNOLOGY IS
CHANGING SO- I THINK THAT WE
NEED- THINK THAT THIS HAS BEEN
UP YOU KNOW WE TOOK VERY- VERY-
PROVIDE A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT WHICH IS VERY HELPFUL FOR
US IN TERMS. OF MAKING
DECISIONS AND MOVING FORWARD.
CHAU AYE I THOUGHT SILVA GROW
REST THAT IS VERY GOOD QUESTION
ABOUT LOOKING FORWARD- YOU KNOW
HOW TO FIND THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN NEW TECHNOLOGIES AND
KIND OF EXISTING PROCESSES
PRIOR TO- THE IMPLEMENTATION
THESE NEW THINGS. SO HOW SHOULD
WE USE THE LEGISLATURE RESPOND.
TO THE L. A. U. S.
RECOMMENDATION. TO INSIST UPON
AND IT YOU KNOW AND- DATE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS AND TO USE AN
EXTERNAL PARTY TO DO THAT. IS
IT IT IS IT IN YOUR VIEW
NECESSARY WOULD IT BE USEFUL.
IS IT UNNECESSARY IF SO. HOW DO
WE MAKE THE CORRECT ALLOCATIONS
TO ACCOUNT FOR THE RIGHT MIX OF
NEW TECHNOLOGY AND SELF HELP
WITH THE OLD PROSTITUTE. WELL I
WOULD SAY WE WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
HAVING TO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THAT WE WILL BE- WITH WITH AND
NOT OUR JUDICIAL COUNCIL DATA
COLLECTION SYSTEMS WILL
ABSOLUTELY BE WATCHING TO SEE
HOW PEOPLE ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES HOW MANY SERVICES ARE
ABLE TO PROVIDE HOW THAT VARIES
BY COUNTY OF THE SORTS OF
THINGS. I DON'T KNOW THAT IT IS
GOING TO BE ENORMOUSLY HELPFUL
TO- HAVE SPECIFIC NUMBERS- YOU
KNOW TO SAY IF- WELL I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE BUT- ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT SELF HELP I WAS
ABLE TO DO WITH THE INCREASE IN
FUNDING. WESTRICK SPAN
SILVERMAN'S OR MRS- WHICH WAS
AS WE DID EARLIER I THINK A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF HOW
WE'RE GOING TO HELP PEOPLE AND
DEAL WITH THIS BACKLOG AND
THOSE KINDS OF SERVICES. AND
THOSE- YOU THINK IT BECOMES YOU
KNOW. DEPENDS ON K. TYPE IT UP
ON MANY FACTORS. IN TERMS OF AN
ALLOCATION OF THOSE RESOURCES-
AND THOSE ARE GOING TO CHANGE
OVER TIME. AND OTHER KINDS OF
THINGS SO I DON'T I WILL SAY AS
A PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR. I
DON'T THINK THAT THE-
ADDITIONAL- TYPE OF ANALYSIS-
THAT IS BEING SUGGESTED BY THE
L. A. R. WILL BE ENORMOUSLY
HELPFUL I THINK WHAT WE CAN DO
IS COME BACK WITH MUCH MORE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION A WE WILL.
AS WE ALWAYS DO- COME BACK WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE NEEDS AND
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED- FROM THE
PROGRAMS AND- AND PROVIDE THAT
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
MOVING FORWARD. SURE THAT IS
CHOI I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
AND MAYBE DOUBLING BACK TO AN
EARLIER I'M SORTS HODGES OF
LAND OKAY AND IT'S SPECIFICALLY
ABOUT A COURT REPORTERS ALL
RIGHT SO OVER THE PAST. NUMBER
HERE'S MY UNDERSTANDING IS
BECAUSE OF BUDGET LIMITATIONS.
YOU HAD TO LIMIT THE HOURS.
BODY FOR CORPORATE- IN THE
VARIOUS. COURTS AND THAT AS A
RESULT IS LIMITED ACCESS TO THE
CONTINUATION OF TRIALS THE
BILLING WHOLE TRIALS. SO WHAT
LOOKING FORWARD. WHAT IS THE
THINKING WITH RESPECT THE
RESTORATION AND WHERE DOES NEW
TECHNOLOGY FIT INTO THAT- IS IT
IN LIEU OF ADDITIONAL- OF THE-
FUNDING FOR TRADITIONAL COURT
REPORTERS FOR IS IT IN IT AS A
COMPLIMENT TO THAT. I AM NOT
PREPARED TO ADDRESS THIS FOR I
DON'T I DON'T MEAN TO SURPRISE
YOU BUT THE APPRECIATE YOUR
ANSWERS TO THE EARLIER
QUESTIONS. I MEAN FOR SOMEONE
ELSE MISTER MISTER- YOUNG MIGHT
BE ABLE TO RESPOND TO THAT CAN
SOMEONE ELSE THIS IS JUDGE
HINRICHS I JUST WANTED TO JUMP
IN ON THE FIRST QUESTION ABOUT
THE I NEED FOR EVALUATION
CERTAINLY THE LEGISLATURE-
SHOULD DO ANY. QUESTION THAT
THEY THINK IS APPROPRIATE FOR
THEIR ALLOCATIONS OF MONIES BUT
I REALLY DO THINK THAT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME IT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. TO ALLOW THE BRANCH
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THOSE
SERVICES AT SELF HELP TO TAKE A
BREATH TO RESET TO RATE RIGHT
SIZE THROUGH THE PANDEMIC AND
THEN TO COME TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE MIGHT JOINTLY
NEED TO. BETTER PROVIDE
SERVICES AND BETTER DEMONSTRATE
TO THE LEGISLATURE WHAT WE'RE
DOING AND HOW IT'S JUSTIFIED-
IT'S JUST A VERY CHALLENGING
TIME FOR THE LEGISLATURE I MEAN
TO THE FOR THE BRANCH BECAUSE-
WE'RE LOOKING AT. HOW TO
TRANSITION THROUGH AND TO GIVE
ANY SORT OF WHAT WHAT TO LOOK
AT NOW IS CHALLENGING BECAUSE
OF HOW WILL BE CHANGED BY THE
PANDEMIC ITSELF. AND WELL I
THINK THE COURT REPORTER
QUESTION MAYBE MORE COMPLEX- IN
A LOT OF COUNTIES IT'S NOT A
QUESTION OF. NOT HAVING
RESOURCES FOR POOR PORTER SO
THAT MAYBE SOMEONE OF AN ISSUE
IS REALLY HAVING ENOUGH FOR
PORTERS- TO. DO THE JOB WITH IN
OUR COURTS JUST THIS LAST WEEK.
WE COULDN'T PROCEED WITH
PULMONARY HEARINGS BECAUSE
THERE WERE NO COURT REPORTERS
AVAILABLE TO. COME TO COURT TO
DO WHAT NEEDED TO BE DONE
BECAUSE OF QUARANTINES AND
OTHER ISSUES SO I THINK THE
COURT PORTER ISSUE IS VERY VERY
COMPLEX AND- WOULD. INVITE A
DEEPER CONVERSATION BUT- BUT IT
IS- CHALLENGING- IN MATTERS AND
I THINK THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE BUT I THINK
THAT'S A LONGER CONVERSATION IN
INTO. OTHER IN OTHER WAYS
YOU'RE A BREACH OF ITS OF MY
UNDERSTANDING SAID THERE'S
BEEN. YOU KNOW A- OF DEFERENCE
GIVEN TO THE G. DISCONTINUED
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH EARLIER- IN HOW
YOU ALLOCATE FUNDING ONCE IT'S
PROVIDED. BUT CLEARLY TO YOUR
POINT THE LACK OF SUFFICIENT
COURT REPORTER RESOURCES. HAS
BEEN A LOOMING FACTOR ON THE
ABILITY OF THE COURTS TO
FUNCTION WELL SO. I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE IS
HAPPY TO GET DEEPLY INVOLVED IN
THAT BUT I'M I'M NOT SURE. WHEN
YOU. THINK ABOUT- DIVISIONS.
OTHER OF THE SEPARATION POWER
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING. YOU FOR.
ARE NO. GOING TO WELCOME I WANT
TO GO BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
QUESTION- ABOUT THE COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF THE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATION. IS THAT WE
REQUIRE ONE AND THAT. THIS COST
WOULD BE ABSORBED. BY THE FUNDS
PROVIDED SO IT WOULD COME AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE ALLOCATION
WE'RE GIVING YOU AND SO YOU
KNOW LOVE FOR YOU TO RESPOND
BECAUSE- THAT SEEMS REASONABLE-
IF YOU IF YOU BUY INTO THE- THE
NEED FOR IT- BUT IF YOU DON'T
BUY INTO THAT NEED I DIED BUT I
WOULD ASSUME THAT YOU DON'T
WANT TO. LOSE THOSE FUNDS TO
THAT BECAUSE- YEAH SO THIS IS
ROBERT A YOUNG FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND I CAN-
ADDRESS THAT AT THIS POINT WE
FEEL THAT THAT IS NOT A GOOD
USE OF THOSE FUNDS- TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS BASICALLY IT
REPRESENTS- AN ADDITIONAL STAFF
FOR NATIONAL ATTORNEY. WHO
COULD BE AT A SELF HELP CENTER
HELPING A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
AND ALTHOUGH I DO ACKNOWLEDGE-
MS LEE'S COMMENTS IN TERMS OF-
THE DESIRE TO HAVE MORE DETAIL
IN THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS.
THE COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS- AS-
NEWS HEALTH MENTIONED IS
COMPLETE AND IT DOES INDICATE
STILL A HIGH NEED FOR MORE
STAFF. FROM THE PUBLIC MORE
STAFF MORE STAFF WHO CAN SPEAK.
LANGUAGES AND SO AT THIS POINT
WE FEEL THAT THE- INVESTMENT
SHOULD GO DIRECTLY TO HELPING
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AT
SOME POINT IN THE FUTURE WE MAY
WISH TO CONDUCT. A ADDITIONAL
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS TO HELP
US IDENTIFY SPECIFIC AREAS FOR
INVESTMENT BUT AGAIN AS
MISSILES HAD MENTIONED- THE
BIGGEST DEMAND RIGHT NOW IS IN
FAMILY LAW. WE HAVE MADE.
TREMENDOUS STRIDES IN EXPANDING
INTO A CIVIL AS WELL AND THE
DATA THAT WE CONTINUE TO
COLLECT POINTS AS TO THOSE
AREAS OF GREATEST NEED. BY THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AND SO WE
FEEL THAT AT THIS POINT WE ARE
NOT AT A POINT WHERE- WE CAN
EVEN SATISFY THE BASIC NEEDS OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
WE FEEL THAT THOSE FUNDS SHOULD
GO DIRECTLY THEIR FIRST. AND AT
SOME POINT LATER. WE CAN LOOK
AT THE- ACERBIC AREA. AND THEN
TO A THE OTHER QUESTION IN
TERMS OF ALLOCATION OF THIS IS
RELATED SOMEWHAT TO COURT
REPORTERS- BUT IN TERMS OF OUR
STRATEGY AND I HAD MENTIONED
THIS EARLIER- RELATED TO REMOTE
HEARINGS. OUR STRATEGY IS NOT
A- STATE OR BE SERVICE
OFFERING. OUR STRATEGY IS
REALLY AND SERVICE OFFERING SO
WE FEEL THAT WE SHOULD BE
OFFERING. PHYSICAL FACE TO FACE
SERVICES AND REMOTE SERVICES
BECAUSE THAT ALLOWS THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE WIDEST- POPULATION
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO DO WANT TO
ACCESS SERVICES REMOTELY AS
WELL AS THOSE. FACE TO FACE SO
OUR STRATEGY FROM A JUDICIAL
BRANCH PERSPECTIVE AND THE AND
THE CHIEFS IN TERMS OF- ACCESS
THREE D. IS REALLY PHYSICAL AND
VIRTUAL BOTH IN SIMULTANEOUS.
SO THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THE
MAXIMUM ACCESS TO JUSTICE. IF
BUT IT DOESN'T THAT YOU HAVE A
PRETTY FUNDAMENTAL. DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION WITH THE L. A. O. AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT YOU'VE MET
THIS REQUIREMENT SO I GUESS I'D
ASK STAFF OR SOMEONE ELSE- IF
YOU COULD PROVIDE THE COMMITTEE
WITH THAT REPORT- THE REPORTS
SUBMITTED- THE REPORTING
QUESTION. IT PROBABLY HELP
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THIS ITEM
OPEN FOR US TO TAKE A LOOK AT
IT AND SEE. WHERE WE FALL
IMAGE. BUT THANK YOU MISTER I
DON'T. L. A. O. PLEASE MISLI. I
WAS JUST GOING TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF ADDITIONAL
CONTACTS FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
AND IN CASE THAT'S HELPFUL FOR
THE SENATORS- SO WHAT KIND OF A
COUPLE ITEMS- FIRST IN TERMS OF
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN LANGUAGE WHEN THIS
REPORT WAS FIRST REQUIRED IT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS THAT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH CAN CONDUCT IT
OR THEY CAN CONTACT WITH THE
RESEARCHER AND IT SPECIFICALLY
SAYS IT IS A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THERE WAS NO ROOM SORT
OF FOR INTERPRETATION- AND SO.
THAT THE OTHER PIECE THAT WE
WOULD SORT OF EMPHASIZE IS
THAT- THE JUDICIAL BRANCH HAS-
HAS CONDUCTED A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
AREA RELATED TO SELF HELP AT
LEAST ACCORDING TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE WHICH WAS A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS OF THE DEAL
HAVE- KIND OF AN IDEA OF WHAT A
COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS WHAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE AND CONSIST OF
WHICH I THINK IS A SOMETHING
THAT STANDS OUT FOR US WHAT YOU
HAVE IN THE REPORT WHEN YOU'LL
GET IT BEFORE YOU. IS SOMETHING
THAT WE RECOGNIZE INCLUDES A
LOT OF VERY HELPFUL OUTCOME
DATA AND IT STARTS DOWN THE
PATH OF IDENTIFYING THE
BENEFITS AND SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THE POTENTIAL COSTS FOR
COMPLETING IT WE DON'T THINK
IT'LL LIKELY EXCEED A COUPLE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT THE
EXTERNAL RESEARCHER WILL BE
ABLE TO USE- SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION A LOT OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS COLLECTED
THEY MIGHT NEED TO SUPPLEMENT
IT BUT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO USE A
LARGE PORTION OF IT SINCE THEN
THE FINISH OFF. A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS KIND OF GOING BACK TO
MY COMMENTS YOU DON'T HAVE YOU
KNOW A COST BENEFIT ANALYSIS
LOOKS AT BENEFITS INSIDE THE
MONETARY VALUE AND IDENTIFY THE
COST YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE THAT
RIGHT NOW THAT'S NOT IN THE
PIECE THAT YOU HAVE. AND THE
CONCEPT FOR ONE OF THE MAJOR
REASONS WHY YOU WHY COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS BE HOPEFUL IS
THAT CAN REALLY HOLE- DETERMINE
HOW WE MAXIMIZE USE OF THE
DOLLARS AND SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
IS THIS NEED FOR SELF HELP.
DOLLARS WE DON'T NECESSARILY
DISAGREE WITH THAT BUT IT'S
ISSUE ABOUT CAN WE- A TARGET IN
USE THAT. SO THAT WE'RE PROVIDE
AS MANY PEOPLE ARE AFFECTED
SERVICES AS POSSIBLE SO TO GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE. COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS MIGHT DETERMINE THAT
WORKSHOPS ARE ONLY REALLY
EFFECTIVE IN CERTAIN CASE
TYPES. SUCH AS LIKE YOU KNOW
YOU'RE STARTING DIVORCES OR
THINGS LIKE THAT FULL ONE ON
ONE SERVICES ARE REALLY. KIND
OF THE MOST- COST BENEFICIAL
AND GUARDIANSHIP OR PROBATE
CASES. AND SO THAT'S HOW THAT
INFORMATION WOULD BE USED TO
INFORM DECISIONS TO MAXIMIZE
THE DOLLARS. IT'S AWFULLY
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT SECOND THAT
THAT'S HELPFUL TO THAT
SENATORS. THANK YOU I THINK
THAT'S VERY. HELPFUL I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SIR NEWMAN- I WOULD.
ENCOURAGE THE JUDICIAL BRANCH-
YOU KNOW TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK
AT THIS- IT WAS THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUDGET THAT
REQUIRED THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO CONDUCT THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS. AND I ASSUMED IT WAS
ACCEPTED BY VIRTUE OF THAT
BUDGET SO I WOULD REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A SECOND
LOOK AND- AND RECONSIDER THE
DOING THAT YOUR YOURSELF OR
GETTING AN OUTSIDER OUGHT TO DO
IT SO THAT WE HAVE THE
INFORMATION THAT THAT WE NEED.
OKAY CENTER COURTESY THANK
VENTURE- THE GREAT DISCUSSION
AT FOR WHATEVER IT'S WORTH AND-
I JUST WANT TO SAY I'M KIND OF
LEANING TOWARD THE- COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS YOU KNOW
MOVING FORWARD BUT- I JUST
WANNA SAY LISTEN TO EVERYONE. I
THINK. THE OIL STARTED TO MAKE.
A GOOD POINT IN TERMS OF HOW
YOU CAN HOW YOU HOLD THIS COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS IF YOU HOLD IT
AS IF YOU LOOK AT IT AS OKAY
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO JUSTIFY
THE COST IN THIS PURPOSE GOING
THROUGH THIS EXERCISE. AS IF
WE'RE TRYING TO CRACK DOWN ON
THE COST- YOU KNOW IT WOULD
PROBABLY FEELS A LITTLE
THREATENING ESPECIALLY TO. YOU
KNOW WHAT IS REALLY A GOOD
PROGRAM OF FAMILIAR WITH THE
PROGRAM NOT ONLY IS A COUNTY
SUPERVISOR BUT AS- YOU KNOW AT
WORK ATTORNEY WHO USED TO
PRACTICE- IN AN AREA WHERE I
GOT TO SEE- THE SELF HELP.
COUNTER AT WORK YOU KNOW THE IN
PERSON CALORIE JUST AS THE
TREMENDOUS THING IS SOMETHING I
THINK YOU'D WANT TO GROW.
CERTAINLY WITH THE NEED- AS
BEST WE CAN HOW TO KEEP UP WITH
THAT NEED DO A COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS THAT ALLOWS US. TO
JUSTIFY. NOT PASS INVESTMENT
WERE CRACKING DOWN ON
INVESTMENT BUT FUTURE IN
AUGMENTATION- YOU KNOW MAYBE IT
MAYBE MAYBE IT WOULD FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE I DON'T KNOW IT SO
IT MAY SOUND LIKE SEMANTICS BUT
I JUST THINK. EVERYONE SAYING
THE SAME THING THIS IS A REALLY
REALLY GOOD THING- IN WE JUST
WANT TO FIGURE OUT. YOU KNOW
HOW TO MAXIMIZE NOT JUST THE
INVESTMENT IN IT BUT THE
PROGRAM ITSELF IN CONTINUE TO
GROW- THAT SAID. I'M GONNA GO
BACK TO MY EARLIER THEME A
LITTLE BIT AND JUST SAY YOU
KNOW THESE CALL CENTERS I
ACTUALLY THOUGHT IF I COULD.
ASK US FOR RESPONSE. TO CHEER
FROM- JUDICIAL COUNCIL- BECAUSE
MISS HUFF THAT WAS WAS SPEAKING
EARLIER- SHE MENTIONED THE
8222% GROWTH JUST ON THE- THE
UNLAWFUL DEATHS DETAINER CIDER
THE LANDLORD TENANT SIDE OF THE
SELF HELP CENTER- AYE AYE.
AGAIN OCCUR EARLY WERE SAYING.
THERE I THINK WE CAN ANTICIPATE
NEED GROWTH OR- DEMAND A THINK
IS A BETTER WORD ON ON SYSTEMS
LIKE THIS CALL CENTER- EVEN
BEFORE THE MORATORIUM IS LIFTED
BECAUSE AS AS LANDLORD TENANT
RELIEF MONEY GOES OUT. IN FOLKS
ARE TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENS OF FI. YOU KNOW MY
LANDLORD APPLIES THE 80% WHAT
HAPPENS YOU KNOW BUT AGAIN THIS
CREE UNLAWFUL DETAINER AND I
KNOW I KNOW THE SELF HELP
CENTER I MEAN TYPICALLY WOULD
BE ENGAGED AT THAT POINT WHERE
THERE'S ALREADY AN UNLAWFUL
DETAINER. SOMEONE COMES IN PRO
PER BASICALLY AND SAYS. I NEED
HELP WITH THIS- AND WOULD LIKE
TO KNOW IS IT IS THERE ANY
LEGAL OBSTACLE. TO THE CALL
SIMPLY SELF HELP CALL CENTERS
BEING DEPLOYED. PRIOR TO WORK
IN ANTICIPATION OF A UT- SO
THAT. WERE NOT BEHIND THE CURVE
WERE NOT FLOODED WITH THESE
CALLS. AFTER ALL THE UNLAWFUL
DETAINERS GET FALL BUT PEOPLE
CAN SCAN COME IN. AND PERHAPS
GET REFERRED TO MEDIATION
PROGRAM OR WHATEVER BUT GET THE
GET TO THE COUNTER. SO THAT
THEY CAN UNDERSTAND. WHAT
THEY'RE TO THE EXTENT THE SELF
HELP CENTERS ARE. ALLOWED TO DO
SO- COMMUNITY GIVE THAT SORT OF
COUNTER ADVICE- EVEN IN VIRTUAL
REALITY. A TO FOLKS WHO ARE- IS
SIMPLY ANTICIPATING- YOU KNOW
THE WORST CASE SCENARIO OR
THREATS BY THEIR LANDLORD IF
IT'S A TENANT- COULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT I JUST PICK IT
WOULD REALLY WANT TO GET TO
HERE IS WHAT'S IS. WHAT'S GOING
TO BE THE GROWTH CURVE OF THIS
EIGHT TO TWENTY TWO. IS THAT
CAN GROW TO A 122% HERE IN A
COUPLE OF WEEKS WIN. WIN MONEY
ROLES- PEOPLE START GETTING
REALLY CONFUSED AS TO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO NEXT.
YES I'D SAY THE ACTUALLY THAT'S
ALREADY HAPPENING IN SELF HELP
CENTERS IN YOUR RIGHT IT IS-
WOULD BE- WILL BE MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE IF PEOPLE HAVE THAT
INFORMATION BEFORE ALL THIS
YET- SO- ABSOLUTELY THAT THE-
WE'VE BEEN DOING TRAINING-
REGULARLY ADAM AS THE LAWS
CHANGE- ON. THE LABOR CANNOT
ALWAYS- YEAH SB NINETY ONE AND
OTHERS SO THAT SELF HELP
CENTERS ARE PREPARED TO ADDRESS
THOSE AND WE'VE DEVELOPED-
SIMPLE FACT SHEETS AND
CHECKLISTS AND RESOURCES AND
INFORMATION. SO ABSOLUTELY
THAT'S TOTALLY WITHIN THE SCOPE
OF THE SELF HELP CENTER- THE
CHALLENGE IS GOING TO BE
FINDING RIGHT THE CHALLENGE IS
GOING TO BE THAT THERE ARE
GOING TO BE. THOSE CALLS AND-
IF YOU KNOW THERE'S MUCH MORE
OF A DEMAND IN THE LANDLORD
TENANT AREA- PEOPLE YOU KNOW WE
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO DO AS MANY
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES OR WE
FAMILY LAW CASES OR OTHER KINDS
OF THINGS SO- I. I THINK THAT
WOULD- SELF HELP CENTERS ARE
REALLY CRITICAL PART OF THE
RESPONSE TIME TO- WEBER TENET
CHALLENGE AND THE OTHER PIECE-IS GOING TO BE ONCE- SOME OF
THOSE CASES HAD SMALL CLAIMS.
OF I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THOSE INCREASE RIGHT BECAUSE
PEOPLE WILL BE GOING TO SPLIT
LANDLORDS PRESUMABLY WILL BE
GOING TO SMALL CLAIMS COURT. TO
BE ABLE TO COLLECT BACK RENT-
IF THEY'RE OT ABLE TO HELP THE
PERSON WITH PROPERTY. AND THERE
ARE NO INJURIES AND SMALL
PLANES AND SO HAVING THE SELF
HELP CENTER ASSISTANCE HELP
PREPARE PEOPLE TO HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
WHICH ARE YOU KNOW. EARLY
COMPLICATED UNDER THE LAW IS
GOING TO BE A SENSE OF. SO AND
I AM I CAN I JUST ALSO SAY I
REALLY RECOGNIZE I THINK WE
ACTUALLY TALK ABOUT A WORKSHOPS
AND WE'RE WORKSHOPS ARE HELPFUL
AND GREATER. CHALLENGES AND I
THINK WE CAME UP WITH A LOT OF
GREAT DATA- THAT I HOPE WILL
INFORM YOUR DECISIONS BUT HAS
CERTAINLY HELPED INFORM OURS
MOVING FORWARD. IN A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS. I JUST. WHAT
I DON'T AYE IT'S IDEA THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR READING. THANK
YOU FOR ME TO THE CHURCH OF
CONCLUDE HERE- IN THE INTEREST
OF TIME A- YEAH I'M NOT BUDGET
WAS THE I'VE ONE NIGHT CRITICAL.
OF THE IS FOR. THE FAR IT TO
FEELS LIKE IT'S SOME FOR WE
WANT TO. GO WITH THIS BENEFIT
NOW. PER A MONOPOLY IT OFF THAT.
THAT SAID. HOW CAN WE GET OR
WHO COULD PROVIDE. GROWTH
METRICS. ALONG THE LINES OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE.
I MEAN I GET IT AT THE ONE AT
ONE POINT. OKAY WELL LEVEL THAT
WE DON'T KNOW- WORKED WITH THIS
COULD BE AN AVALANCHE OR OR-
UGH JUST AN INCREASING SORT OF
TRICKLE. OF GROWTH- BUT
WHATEVER. YOU FOLKS WOULD WOULD
ANTICIPATE IN A WORST CASE
SCENARIO SORRY ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO LEASE CASE THE LEAST WORST
CASE SCENARIO IS IT POSSIBLE
JUST TO GET SOME MATH JUST TO
GET SOME ARITHMETIC ON THAT
EITHER TO WORK. OUR STAFF HERE
A CONSULTANT FOR OR DIRECTLY TO
THESE OFFICES ARE BOTH- I JUST
THINK WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL
GOING FORWARD SO WE IF THERE IS
SOMETHING WE WANT TO DO. AND
I'M NOT. YOU KNOW IN ANY WAY
TRY TO PREDISPOSE THE ATTITUDES
AMONG MY COLLEAGUES WHO TAKES
BOTH TO DO THINGS BUT IF THERE
IS AN INTEREST IN MAKING SURE.
THAT WE DON'T SHORT CHANGE THIS
PART OF THE EFFORT TO CALL
CENTER AND SO FORTH. I THINK
WOULD BE GOOD FOR US TO HAVE
NUMBERS ON THE TABLE. THE THAT
WE CAN. THAT WE CAN LOOK AT
RATHER THAN. NOT HAVE THOSE
NUMBERS IN IN JUST ESSENTIALLY
WHAT SOME POINT BE TAKING A
VOTE ON. YOU KNOW WHAT IS IN
FRONT OF US RIGHT WE CAN'T WE
CAN'T MAKE UP THE NUMBERS HERE
SO THAT. CAN YOU CAN HELP WITH
THAT. AND IF I COULD JUST BAD-
SECRETARY IF I COULD JUST ADD
THAT I THINK- THE- WHEN THIS
PANDEMIC KID AND WE WERE FACED
WITH MAKING DECISIONS LIKE THE
REPORT TORY ELEMENT. AND ALL
THE OTHER EMERGE REGENCY
DECISIONS- IT- WE WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE WITH THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH ON YOU KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE ANY POTENTIAL EVICTIONS
OR OF PROBLEMS THAT RENT IS
WE'RE GONNA BE HAVING BUT
ESPECIALLY FICTIONS. BUT SEEMS
TO ME HERE'S LIKE A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT AGAIN
THIS IS WHAT THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH IS DOING THIS IS WHAT
YOU DISH OF BRANCH COULD BE
DOING AND MAKE SURE WERE AS
CONNECTED AS POSSIBLE WITH. THE
FUNDING ON THE POLICIES AND
THOSE OF YOU KNOW ALL THE GREAT
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND DOING WORK
LIKE AROUND THE SELF HELP THAT
THAT SHOULD BE AS COORDINATED
AS POSSIBLE TO GET THE MOST OUT
OF IT BECAUSE- IN SOME WAYS WE
WERE GETTING PAST THE PANDEMIC
WAS TRYING TO GET PAST IT AND
ON THE HEALTH FRONT. HEALTH
CARE FRONT. BUT THERE IS A LOT
MORE THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WHEN EVERYBODY THINKS IT'S ALL
SORT OF BACK TO NORMAL
ESPECIALLY WITH REGARDS TO
RENTERS. I'M SORRY FOR THE
INTERRUPTION. OKAY I GUESS AS
WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU ON THAT OKAY. GREAT THANK
YOU- THE RECOMMENDATION IS TO
HOLD OPEN- AND WE MOVE ON TO
ISSUE THREE. TRAINER GET
THROUGH HERE- THE ABILITY TO
PAY EXPANSION- BASICALLY AND
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- WHO WILL
PRESENT AFTER THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH. AND WILL START TO
INTRODUCTION AN ALTERNATE
OVERNIGHT I'M SHELLING KERN FOR
ANY NEW QUESTIONS IN THE HOUSE.
OKAY SURE I'M SORRY. I WILL
CHOOSE THE YES AND THEN TURNED
OVER TO MICHELLE AND CONGRESS
LONG IN QUESTIONS OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL REQUESTING A
TWELVE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN A POSITIONS IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO CREASING
THE EIGHTY EIGHT POINT FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS BY TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. FOR STATEWIDE
OPERATE. JUDY KIDDING ALL TYPES
OF INFRACTIONS OF ON LINE OUT
OPTIONS INCLUDING PROCESSING
ABILITY TO PAY THE NATION'S.
THE NEXT THREE FISCAL YEARS
JUST A COUNCIL WORKER REPORT
ECHO FOUR TWO DOT NEW
TECHNOLOGY THE FUNDING INCREASE
EACH YEAR UNTIL FOR THE POINT.
WEST ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING TO
BACKFILL THE ESTIMATED LOSS IN
READY TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
FUNDS GRANTING FINANCIER
REDUCTIONS BASED ON ABILITY TO
PAY. REQUEST WILL EXPAND UPON A
PILOT PROGRAM APPROVED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT
WHICH IMPLEMENTED ONLINE
TRAFFIC EDUCATION AND THE
ABILITY TO PAY PROJECTS IN THE
COURTS. SPENDING THIS PROGRAM
STATEWIDE AMOUNTS OF FISSION
SHE'S BY USING TECHNOLOGY FOR
ONLINE EDUCATION INSTRUCTIONS
AND PROVIDES TARGETED RELEASE
LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS ALLOWING
THEM TO APPLY ONLINE HEATHER
FINES AND FEES REDUCED BASED ON
THEIR ABILITY TO PAY. WE'RE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
AGAIN WE HAVE SHOWN KERN AND
HIS NATIONAL LETTER HERE TO
RESPOND AND QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU- WITH FINANCE LIKE TO MAKE
ANY COMMENTS. BERMAN FINANCING
JUST LIKE TO ADD EXTENSIONS
FIVE OF HIS PROVIDES TARGETED
OR WE GET THOSE WHO NEED IT
MOST AND ALLOW FOR FURTHER
MODERNIZATION FOR OPERATIONS
GIVEN THE BURDEN FINDING THESE
CURRENTLY HABITABLE TO. YOU
WANT TO EXTEND THE LEAD TO SUCH
INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY LIVE. FURTHERMORE THIS
PROPOSAL ALLOWS FOR THE TRIAL
COURTS TO MODERNIZE THE SHOW
FEATURES SUCH AS ONLINE
EDUCATION OF FRACTIONS WHICH
FURTHER PROMOTES ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR USERS. AND ALSO
WANTED TO COMMENT ON A FEW OF
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY L. A. L.
I NEED WILL BREAK THEM DOWN
ROTH THOROUGHLY. PRESENTATION
IN REGARDS TO THIS THING
FRIEDMAN SHARE ALTHOUGH WE DO
NOT HAVE COMPREHENSIVE
REPORTING ON THE RESULTS FROM
THE HIGHWAY THE PRELIMINARY
OUTCOMES FROM THE PARTICIPATING
FOR SENATE IMPLEMENTED EIGHTY
KIANA VALUATIONS IS PROMISING.
AND HAS REDUCED FRIENDS EXCUSE
FOR LONG COMMUNITIES WALLS
COVERING FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS AS OF JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST OF THIS YEAR WE
ARE PROPOSING A PHASED ROLLOUT
OF THE PROGRAM AND
INSTITUTIONAL DATA BECOMES
AVAILABLE WE WILL BE ABLE TO
MAKE ANY NECESSARY CHANGES. OR
THE ABILITY OF A PROGRAM. ALSO
THE THAT THE THIS BUILDING WILL
DOESN'T WORK WHEN FOR THE-
OVERALL TYLER PORT IN ALL OF
THE WORK. THAT MAKES. IN A DA
ONLINE. HATE HOWEVER WE ARE
OPEN WORKING WITH LET'S PACKS
L. A. THE REFINE THE REPORT
LANGUAGE IS. AT THE TRAILER TO
LANGUAGE. ON THE L. A. L. HAS
ALSO CAN ABOUT FUTURE COST
INCREASES FOR THE OTHER
FEATURES PORTABILITY HEY WE
JUST LIKE TO NOTE THAT COSTS
MAY INCREASE IN THE FUTURE TO
IMPLEMENT THE OTHER FEATURES
INCLUDED. ON HOWEVER IS
pMODERNIZATION VESTMENTS IN THE
TRAVELS TO PROMOTE ACCESS. TO
JUSTICE JANAK TARGET. I
SPECIFICALLY IN THE- OF ONLINE
AND- THIS WOULD BE EXTREMELY
HELPFUL FOR USERS THEM TO
RESOLVE. BUSINESS WITHOUT HAVE
IT TAKES OFF WORK OR AWAY FROM
NEXT TO WHICH A- PRISTINE FOR
FRACTION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MISLI. IS A MYSTERY OR YEAH.
YES I NEARLY WITH THE L. A. L.
SO WE HAVE FOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
ON THIS ISSUE ITEM BEFORE YOU
SO FIRST WE ARE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE REJECTS
THE PROPOSED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CANCEL THE
PILOT CANCEL THE REQUIRED
EVALUATION AND EXPAND THE POOL
ONLINE- THIS IS. THIS IS
BECAUSE IN A CERTAIN COMPONENTS
OF THE TOOL ARE STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING FINALIZED AND
IMPLEMENTED SO FOR EXAMPLE
ONLINE TRIALS ARE NOT SLATED TO
ACTUALLY COME ONLINE UNTIL- YOU
KNOW A COUPLE MONTHS FROM NOW
AND SO IT COULD MEAN THAT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH IT ARE
DIFFERENT- IN ADDITION IN TERMS
OF THE EVALUATION WE WOULD KNOW
THAT. WHAT IS REQUIRED UNDER
EXISTING LANGUAGE IN THE
EVALUATION IS DIFFERENT FROM
THE REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT IS
CURRENTLY ON IN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE BEFORE YOU AND
SO- MORE COMPLETE DATA FROM THE
EVALUATION OF THE COMPLETED
HIGH LET IS NECESSARY BECAUSE
IT CAN HELP INFORM- THE
LEGISLATURE ON THE FULL IMPACT
OF ALL OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT
WERE BEING TESTED WHICH COULD
THEN BE USED TO INFORM FUTURE
LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER HIGHER
REDUCTIONS FOR INCOME- FOR
THOSE WHO FALL WITHIN THE
DEFINITION OF LOW INCOME. OR
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT
PROVIDING AN AUTOMATIC
PRODUCTION FOR ADDITIONAL
CATEGORIES OF INDIVIDUALS SUCH
AS PEOPLE WHO DON'T CURRENTLY
FALL WITHIN THE DEFINITION OF
LOW INCOME SO THESE ARE AND
THAT'S WHAT IS THAT COULD HAVE-
DECISIONS THAT COULD BE
INFORMED. BY THE EVALUATION.
UPSET WE DO. THAT THE ABILITY
TO PAY COMPONENT OF THE KIND
THAT DEFINITELY PROVIDES
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS AND
PROMOTES. EQUITY AND SO TO
FURTHER THAT WE WOULD-
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
THOUGH ONLY IMPROVE THE TWELVE
POINT THREE MILLION REQUESTED
IN THE BUDGET. SO THAT WOULD
ROLL OUT TO ADDITIONAL TEN
COURTS AS ENVISIONED BY THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH THAT WOULD
PROVIDE MORE PEOPLE WITH
FINANCIAL RELIEF FROM PROMOTE.
EIGHT BUT IT WOULD PREVENT THE
PROGRAM FROM AUTOMATICALLY
CONTINUING BEYOND THE BUDGET
YEAR BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
AN OPPORTUNITY A CLEAR
OPPORTUNITY OF CLEAR BREAK TO
DETERMINE WHAT CHANGES IF ANY
THAT IT WANTS TO MAKE- FROM
BASED OFF OF THE INFORMATION
THAT I GOT FROM THE EVALUATION-
OUR THIRD RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT THERE IS PROPOSED-
PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE THAT WOULD
AUTHORIZE FINANCE TO ALLOCATE
THE BACK FULL REVENUES. AMONGST
THE VARIOUS JUDICIAL BRANCH
FUNDS WE THINK THAT THAT MAKES
SENSE BECAUSE IT'S REALLY A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE AMOUNT PROVIDED
IS COMMENSURATE WITH A LOT- AND
OUR FINAL RECOMMENDATION IS.
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
PROPOSES TO AUTHORIZE TRIAL
COURTS TO CONDUCT ALL
INFRACTION PROCEEDINGS REMOTELY
UPON CONSENT OF THE DEFENDANT
WHICH WOULD BE BEYOND TO THE
OFFICES OF THIS ONLINE TOOL- WE
DO RECOGNIZE THAT IT CAN
PROMOTE EQUITY AND INCREASE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO THE COURTS.
AND THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
APPROVE IT WE DO RECOMMEND
THOUGH THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DIRECT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
SUBMIT AN EVALUATION OR REPORT
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
LANGUAGE AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THERE'S CURRENTLY QUITE A BIT
OF UNKNOWNS. FOR EXAMPLE WE
ACTUALLY DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
KNOW WHICH COURTS HOW MANY
QUARTS WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS AUTHORIZATION AND EXACTLY
HOW THEY WOULD IMPLEMENT THAT.
IN LINE WITH THAT THERE'S ALSO
NOT QUITE CLEAR IMPACT ON WHAT
THE IMPACT WOULD BE ON CORE
OPERATIONS ARE COSTS SO FOR
EXAMPLE- REMOTE PROCEEDINGS MAY
BE MORE CONVENIENT FOR
INDIVIDUALS AND SO YOU MIGHT
HAVE INDIVIDUALS WHO CHOOSE TO
CONTEST. AND FRACTIONS- MORE SO
THAN THEY OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE
DONE THEY WOULD NORMALLY JUST
PAID OFF AND SO THAT COULD LEAD
TO INCREASED WORKLOAD. ON THE
FLIP SIDE THIS COULD BE A MORE
EFFICIENT WAY OF DEALING WITH
THESE CASES BUT BECAUSE WE
DON'T KNOW I'M THAT WHAT THE
IMPACT WOULD BE REPORTING WOULD
BE REALLY HELPFUL- TO INFORM
FUTURE LEGISLATIVE DECISIONS
SUCH AS WHETHER OR NOT REMOTE
PROCEEDING SHOULD BE EXPANDED.
TO OTHER CASE TYPES FOR EXAMPLE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FROM. IS
THE I HAVE A QUESTION FOR OF
FINANCE MISTER ROMIJN YOU
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT- THE
PHASED ROLLOUT THAT YOU'D BE
OPEN DID I HEAR YOU'RE RIGHT WE
SAID DID YOU BE OPEN TO THAT IS
THAT DIFFERENT FROM WHAT THE
MISS LEE JUST SAID ABOUT HIS
GOING TO THE TEN ADDITIONAL
COURTS AND NOT- OR DID I. GET
THAT RIGHT. ISN'T THAT THEM THE
SAME THING THAT YOU'RE SAYING
ARE YOU SAYING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT RESTORE ONLY. NOT
FROM MY DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO IT WOULD AND HE DOES
ALLUDING TO IS IF OF THE
VARIOUS PARTIAL EXPANSION JUST
FOR THAT FIRST IN THE FIRST
BUDGET YEAR. TO THE I THINK IT
WOULD A TEN COURTS WHERE ARE
PROPOSAL IS JUST A PHASE
ROLLOUT. MORE OF A OF COURSE
EACH YEAR WE HAVE THAT A
NATIONAL INITIAL ROLLOUT THAT
MEET ADDRESS AND THEN TWENTY
YEAR YEAR BASIS WE HAD ON INTEL
EVENTUALLY WE GET TO. EXPANSION
DAHLE FIFTY WORKS. IN AND THAT
COME SOME ADDITIONAL ADDITIONAL
FUNDING THAT IS REQUIRED TO
TWELVE POINT THREE MILLION IN
THE BUDGET YEAR GOES UP TO THE
YEAR FOLLOWING UP TO TWENTY
FIVE ONE. MILLION AND THEN
FORTY SEVEN MILLION FALLING
BACK AND THEN IN TOTAL WHEN
THIS IS BANG WE SHOP ALL OF THE
TRIAL COURT FIFTY EIGHT POINT
ONE DOLLARS. RIGHT AND THEN
YOU'RE SAYING APPROVED THAT NOW
THE ONE APPROVAL TO DO ALL OF
IT NOW OVER FACETIME NOT. TO IT
ONE YEAR FOR TEN COURTS AND
THEN. TAKE IT FROM THERE. YES
THANK YOU THANKS A LOT ALL
FIFTY. SOME AND- HAVE ALL OF
THAT THE TOOLS FUNCTIONS BEEN
ROLLED OUT. FOR IT TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON THE ON THE
OPERATIONS OF THE OKAY THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I'M
SHELLEY KERN I'M- THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SERVICES OFFICE OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AM I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON. IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR QUESTION MADAM CHAIR- ALL
OF THE FUNCTIONS IN MY
CITATIONS ARE FULLY DEVELOPED
NOW AND THEY'RE IN HOUSTON IN
THE SIX COUNTIES THAT ARE-
CURRENTLY UP AND RUNNING- OF
THE ONLINE TRAVEL THURMOND
DECLARATION FEATURE IS ALSO
FULLY DEVELOPED- IT INCLUDES
LIVE AGAIN COURT AN OFFICIAL-
JUDICIAL OFFICER MODULES. AND
THAT THAT FEATURE IS NOW IN
DEPLOYMENT IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY- THE LANGUAGE IN THE
STATUTE REQUIRES THE PILOT
COURTS OFFER LITIGANTS OPTIONS
FOR AT LEAST THREE FUNCTIONS IN
ADDITION TO THE ABILITY TO PAY-
AND ALL. PORTS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THAT. THANK YOU. COULD YOU JUST
SEE- GET AS AS AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS WHAT PIECES OF INFORMATION
KIND OF WALK ME THROUGH QUICKLY
WHAT PIECES OF INFORMATION WITH
SOMEONE ON PUBLIC ASSISTANCE OR
WHO MEETS THE POVERTY
GUIDELINES WHAT WOULD THEY NEED
TO SUBMIT TO RECEIVE THE
REDUCTION IN THEIR FINANCE AND
OR FEES. YEAH SURE SO THE WEED
CONTROL WORKS IS- AN INDIVIDUAL
AND A DEMO OF OUR TOOL ACTUALLY
IS AVAILABLE ONLINE SO PEOPLE
CAN CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
LINDA JO GETS ONLINE AND THEY
CAN USE EITHER THEIR COMPUTER
OR TABLET OR THEIR CELL PHONE-
THEY ENTER THEIR CITATION
NUMBER AND WHERE THEY RECEIVE
THEIR CHEQUE AT AFTER THAT THEY
HAVE AN OPTION TO PROCEED IN
SPANISH FOR AN ENGLISH- AND
THEN THERE ARE ASKED SEVERAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT THEIR INCOME SO
AFTER. QUESTION I REALLY
QUESTION ABOUT THE **** ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY RECEIVE
CERTAIN PUBLIC ASSISTANCE
BENEFITS- IF THEY SAY YES THAT
THEY RECEIVE THE BENEFIT THEY
HAVE THE OPTION OF ACTUALLY
TAKING PHOTOGRAPHS OF THEIR
BENEFITS SO- A BENEFIT CARD AND
UPLOADING IT TO THE JUDICIAL
OFFICER CAN CONSIDERATE- THEY
ALSO PROVIDE INFORMATION ABOUT
THEIR INCOME- HOUSEHOLD
EXPENSES. HOUSEHOLD SIZE AND
THEN THEY SUBMIT BACK. TO THE
COURT FOR CONSIDERATION. THROOP
BY TAKING A PICTUREIT AND-
YEAH THANK YOU BUT IF THEY DO.
HAVE ABILITY TO DO THAT FOR ANY
REASON THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE PROOF OF INCOME- THEN
THEY CAN JUST EXPLAIN THERE'S A
PLACE ON ON THE ON THE TOOL
WHERE THEY CAN EXPLAIN- THAT
THEY ARE RECIPIENTS BUT FOR
SOME REASON THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE. A PROOF OF INCOME AND
EXPLAINED WHY IT IS THAT
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO PROVIDE
PROOF OF INCOME- AND ALSO ANY
OTHER EXPENSES THEY MIGHT HOUSE
OF THEY'VE GOT MEDICAL DATA OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THEY WERE
ABLE TO INCLUDE THAT. ALSO
THROUGH THE TOOL AS WELL. AND
ARE ALL THE PILOT COURTS MAKING
ABOUT FIFTY. 50% REDUCTION.
FROM FOR THOSE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
REDUCTION. EIGHT TOOL.
DEPARTMENT THE STATUTE ITSELF
RECTIFIED REQUIRES THAT- THE
TOOL RECOMMENDS AT LEAST A 50%
REDUCTION AND SO WE HAVE A BY.
A VARIETY OF- RESPONSES AMONG
THE COURTS IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY. BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY PROVIDING TO-
RECIPIENTS. SO THE AVERAGE IS
52% ACROSS THE STATE IS WHAT
PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING- WE HAVE
SOME COURTS THAT FOR THE
AVERAGE IS HIGHEST. AT SEVENTY
SIX PERCENT. AND SOME BETTER
BETTER 41% GIVEN THAT- WE'RE
GOING THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
WAYS OF RELIEVING. FINANCIAL
HARDSHIPS AND BARRIERS OF. HAS
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
pRECONSIDERED CHANGES TO THE
ELIGIBILITY PERCENT REDUCTION
OR MANDATING USE OF THE
REDUCTION ON UPON STOP
STATEWIDE ROLLOUT. WELL THAT
THIS IS THE BILL LANGUAGE IS
ACTUALLY IN STATUTE THAT SAYS
THE TOOL HAS TO RECOMMEND AT
LEAST A 50% REDUCTION SO WE'RE
HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT- PEOPLE WANT TO
CONSIDER- WE DO THINK THAT
THERE'S A REAL IMPORTANCE OF
JUDICIAL DISCRETION JUDICIAL
OFFICERS GET THIS INFORMATION
THEY LOOK AT A VARIETY OF-
FACTORS IN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION- 475% OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE MAKING THE REQUEST
ACTUALLY RECEIVE REDUCTIONS SO
WE ARE SEEING. YOU KNOW
SIGNIFICANT- MOVEMENT IN THIS
REGARD AND FOR THOSE WHO ARE
NOT RECEIVING REDUCTIONS SO
SURE REJECTED MAJORITY OF
THOSE- HAVE TO DEAL WITH- THEY
THEY IT'S A DUPLICATE REQUESTS
RIGHTS OF 38% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
REJECTED HAVE A DUPLICATE
REQUEST- 31% OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
IN REJECTED- WHO DON'T RECEIVE
REDUCTIONS HIS MATE- DON'T
RECEIVE A REDUCTION BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE REQUESTING A
REDUCTION FOR. A TYPE OF CASE
IT IS NOT ELIGIBLE SO
MISDEMEANOR FOR EXAMPLE- 8% OF
THE TIME PEOPLE ACTUALLY
ALREADY PAID OFF THEIR TRAFFIC
TICKETS SO MOST OF THE TIME
PEOPLE ARE RECEIVING
REDUCTIONS. IN THOSE PLACES
WHERE THEY'RE NOT RECEIVING
REDUCTIONS A LOT OF TIMES IT'S
FOR THE REASONS THAT I HATE
THAT I SUGGESTED AND- WE ARE AS
I SAID AT THE BEGINNING WE'RE
WE'RE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- ON ON.
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED.
OKAY COLLEAGUE. QUEST NOW. NO
THREE YOU COULD REDUCE OKAY
OKAY OF. OKAY WE'RE GONNA AS-
THAT CORRECT HOLD OPEN THIS
ITEM WE WANT TO ISSUE FOR-
THESE ARE ON VARIOUS
MAINTENANCE AND FACILITY
MODIFICATION PROPOSALS.
ESSENTIALLY THIS IS LIKE
COMPARING THE CHANNEL BRIEFLY
JUST TOUCH ON AND THE NUMBER OF
ITEMS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THIS- FIRST IS A THIRTY NINE
DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION ON FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WE CURRENTLY HAVE
OVER FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE NEEDS. WE
HAVE RECEIVED A ONE TIME THE
PUBLICATIONS FOR THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS- SO THIS IS A
VERY CRITICAL TIME INVESTMENT
IS LINDROS VITAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE IN TRIAL COURTS AND
APPELLATE COURTS ARE USED TO
SUPPORT MODERNIZATION OF
BUILDING MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS H.
FAQ. ELEVATORS REPLACEMENTS ON
MY- MY NUMBER OF CRITICAL
ISSUES THAT- I'M STAYING IN THE
OPERATIONS OF. THE TRIAL AND
APPELLATE COURTS. SECOND
PURPOSE IS. TO CENTRO WHAT
MONTH. THE SUBSTITUTED BY-
SINCE THE- IN OUR FIRE LIFE
SAFETY SYSTEMS THE DEFINED BY
THE STATE FARM MARSHALL- AND-
DECLARE THERE ARE PROJECTS IN
ORANGE AND SAN DIEGO COUNTIES
THAT NEED. ATTENTION INSURE
THAT THEY ARE. SAFE FROM
OPERATING FACILITIES. THIRD AND
I THINK THIS IS A PRETTY
CRITICAL PROPOSAL FOR US- HIS
RELATES TO ON TRIAL COURT IN A
COURT OF APPEAL FACILITY
MAINTENANCE LEASES. AND
INCREASE OF FIFTY THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
ON IN FACT ASSISTANCE TO
SUPPORT AND THE- FACILITY
MAINTENANCE. AT OUR TRANSPORT
IMPORTS OF PEELS- THIS IS AN
AREA OF NEED I'M IN WHICH YOU
WERE GLAD TO SEE THE BUDGET IS
SUPPORTING- WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ARE. A SIGNIFICANT A
PORTFOLIO OF FACILITIES IS
ADEQUATELY MAINTAINED. AND AS
IT STANDS NOW WE ARE NOT AT THE
LEVELS OF INDUSTRY STANDARDS
AND THAT IS LEADING TO-
UNDERVALUATION WITHOUT
FACILITIES AND SO. OVER
CHRISTIAN OF PROPOSED. AND HOPE
TO FIND YOUR IS GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS. WE DO HAVE. HELLO
COMMITTEE IN JENKINS VALE
SERVICE AND SPECIFIC ABOUT
THESE THREE. MY NAME AND ARE
SHOULD RESPOND IN THE- THANK
YOU- FINANCE IS IT WAS TO
REMIND. HI JESSICA NINE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO ADD ON TO THE TRIAL
COURT OF THE FACILITY
MAINTENANCE PROPOSAL JUST FOR
BACKGROUND PURPOSES BETWEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET. INCLUDED
TWENTY POINT NINE MILLION
ONGOING GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE FOR
TRAVEL SO HE'S CONTRACTED SINCE
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN WHICH IS ONE
FACILITIES WERE TRANSFERRED TO
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL PORTFOLIO
AND THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF FUNDING
AVAILABLE BASED ON THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ISSUE STANDARD FOR
THE REST OF THE YEAR SO. SHE
THE REST OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S BUILDING PORTFOLIO IF
SO HE'S CONDUCTED PRIOR TO TWO
THOUSAND SO IT'S FUNDING IS
VITAL TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
TO MAINTAIN THEIR FACILITIES.
BY MAKING THESE INVESTMENTS
ALLOWING FOR TRANSPORTING
COURTS OF APPEALS TO BE FUNDED
HAPPEN YOU INDUSTRY STANDARD
THE ENTIRE PORTFOLIO THIS WILL
PREVENT. FUTURE CITY
MAINTENANCE ISSUES. VIRGINIA
FLOODING AND AS WELL AS TO
NAMES ISSUES. I'M INTERESTED IN
TO L. L. COMMENTING. RE DIRECT.
ON BEING- SINCE THE IMMEDIATE
ACT PACKAGE RESTORE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX POINT NINE MILLION
ON. YEAH FUND SUPPORT THE
TRANSPORT. THAT REDIRECTION
FIFTY TWO POINT FOUR ASKS
REFERENCE FOR THE L. A. L. I'M-
WELL IN OUR FIRST THIS NO
LONGER WOULD BE NEXT. IN THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH CELANESE SHOULD
STILL BE PRIORITIZE FUNDING.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISLI- I
NEED A LEAD OUT WITH THE L. A.
I. I'M SO WE DON'T HAVE
SPECIFIC CONCERNS WITH THESE
PROPOSALS- WHAT MR MINE WAS
REFERENCING WAS THAT- THIS WAS
ONE OF THE OPTIONS THAT WE PUT
ON THAT WE OFFER TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS A CONSIDERATION
AS YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL. OF FUNDING
TO PROVIDE TO THE TRIAL COURTS
AND SPECIFICALLY HOW YOU'RE
ALLOCATING. THE DOLLARS AND SO-
IF THE LEGISLATURE DESIRE TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL MONEY OR YOU
KNOW. PUT IT INTO A PARTICULAR
POT FOR EXAMPLE TO DRESS
PANDEMIC RELATED ðPONSES
WERE JUST SAYING THIS WAS ONE
OF THE ITEMS THAT YOU COULD
POTENTIALLY REACH IRAQ'S- BUT
MISTER I HAS A- VERY APT POINT
WHERE RESTORATION OF THE TWO
HUNDRED MILLION WHICH WAS. JUST
A RECENTLY PROPOSED. THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU- I HAVE A
QUESTION A ONE SORRY YES THAT
WAS IT- COULD YOU EXPLAIN THE
NEED FOR THE FIVE POSITIONS OF
AND WHAT WOULD THESE FIVE
POSITIONS BE DOING THAT THE
CURRENT FORTY THREE POSITIONS
THAT ARE DEDICATED TO FACILITY
OPERATIONS CAN'T DO. HELLO
MCCORMICK RESPONDED THAT
QUESTION THAT AND SHARE. SO
YOUR SYSTEMS ARE ALL WORKING.
IT IS NOT CURRENTLY USED TO
SING WITH LONGER IF HE'S
AVAILABLE. THE DALLAS ON THE
SCREEN. SHE WAS ON THE NEEDED.
ASSISTING WHOSE- VIDEOS LIVE
OKAY AND TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND
GO AHEAD MR SINGH. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JACK
AND SAYING I'M THE PRINCIPAL
MANAGER AND FACILITY SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ANSWER THE QUESTION SO THESE
POSITIONS ARE GOING TO BE
SPREAD THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WE
CURRENTLY HAVE A- DEFICIT
WITHIN OUR EXISTING OPERATIONS
DR. WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFF
TO DO ALL THE PREVENTIVE OF
VERY FILE THE PREVENTIVE
MAINTENANCE THAT'S BEEN GOING
ON SO THESE POSITIONS ARE BEING
REQUESTED ONE IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA ONE IN THE AREA TO
IN THE SOUTHERN REGION AND WON
A SUPERVISOR WHICH WILL BE A
STATE REGULATION. SO THOSE ARE
THE FIVE POSITIONS THAT WE ARE
REQUESTING AS YOU NO GCC
PORTFOLIO IS FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTY COURTS LIKE THIS. PLEASE
AND- SO THESE WILL BE IN OF
THESE FIVE POSITIONS BE
DEPLOYED SO THAT. BECAUSE OF.
L. THIS SIZE OF THE CERTAIN
REGIONS WHERE- WE HAVE ALL THE
WAY FROM OREGON BORDER. OF SAN
FRANCISCO THAT WE HAVE ADEQUATE
COVERAGE IN THERE AND- ALL. IT
WILL ALSO PROVIDE STAFF
EFFICIENCY AND- AND MORE TIME
WILL BE DEDICATED BY. BY THE
STAFF TO MAINTENANCE ISSUES AND
INCREASED OVERSIGHT OF
PREVENTIVE MAINTENANCE PROGRAM
AND LESS- NONPRODUCTIVE TIME TO
TRAVEL BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
FACILITIES. OF OUR CURRENT
FACILITIES OPERATIONS STOPS THE
DISTRIBUTED IN TWENTY DIFFERENT
COURTHOUSE LOCATIONS IN EACH
REGIONS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR.
ADMINISTRATING SERVICES TO ALL
THEIR PROBLEMS IF YOUR
CREATIONS. OF THE FIVE
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS OF FOCUS
IN THAT AREA REGIONS WHERE ARE.
THE LONGEST IN THE LEAST
PRODUCTIVE. TRAVEL TIME BETWEEN
THE COURTS AS AN EXAMPLE
KRISTOFFERSON'S RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE BUTTE COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT
COMPLEX AN AUDIBLE IS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE MODOC
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT IN OUTROS
SPEECHES OR FOUR HOURS DRIVE
FROM ALL REALLY. AND THE MORE
SEVERE COLD WHICH IS A MEMBER
PLAGUE SWITCHES FIREHOUSE FORM
STRIVE FOR MORE WILL. SO IN
ORDER. NATION'S LIKE A LADY
TRAFFIC CONDITIONS DRINKING
BACK TO SOUTH INDIA AS WELL.
OKAY WELL. THE. I'M NOT SURE
THAT COVERS AND SATISFIES MY-
QUESTION- COLLEAGUES DOES
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THIS ITEM NOW. OKAY LET'S MOVE
ON THEN HOLDING THAT OPEN ISSUE
FIVE IS ON THE CONSTRUCTION
FUND CONSOLIDATION TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. AGAIN THIS IS LIKE OF
EUROVISION'S COUNCIL CAN
PROVIDE YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW
THE AGENDA DOES A FINE JOB OF
PLANET BUT ALSO TO START WITH
THE ISSUE OF. FINDING FEE
REVENUES- THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IS
HEARD OVER THE YEARS ISSUES
WITH DECLINING- CRIMINAL
REVENUES IN FINES AND FEES FROM
THAT SOURCE THE- TWO OF OUR-
SIGNIFICANT CONSTRUCTION FUNDS
THE SAUDI FUNDS THE LION PART
ON THOSE REVENUES TO SUPPORT
THEIR OWN EXPENSES. MMHM IS HE
SAID THAT AS A RESULT OF THE
DECLINING REVENUES HERE ON OUR
STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUND IS FACING
INSOLVENCY IN THE NEXT FISCAL
YEAR OTHER GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
IS TO COMBINE THIS FUND WITH
ANOTHER PHONE CALL THE
IMMEDIATE AND CRITICAL NEEDS
ACCOUNTS. INTO A SINGLE FUND
I'M AND AT THAT MEETING
CRITICAL NEEDS ACCOUNT HAS
REVENUES THAT CAN SUPPORT. THE
OTHER FIND AND TRY NOT TO MAKE
IT TOO COMPLICATED THE BEST A
GREAT AS ENOUGH IN THE BANK TO
HELP COVER THE SHORTFALL IN THE
OTHER ACCOUNTS. FOR IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. MY LONG TERM RISK-
WE WOULD BE WITH DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND ALLEGED- TO LOOK
AT- GENERAL FUND OPTIONS WELL
WE REALLY DON'T HAVE FINANCED
THE- SOLUTIONS TO ADDRESS THE
ONGOING INSOLVENCY. OF THESE
FUNDS AND SO WE WOULD BE
DEFINITELY LOOKING TOWARDS-
GENERAL FUND. AS THE SOLUTION
FOR THAT AGAIN THAT IS- TO WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION LET'S
SEE TO DO SO. ON THESE FUNDS
PROVIDE- COULD COST OF REVENUES
TO COVER. THAT SERVICE WHICH IS
VERY CRITICAL EXPENSE OF OURS-
FACILITY MODIFICATIONS ARE
COURTHOUSES ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE FUNCTIONING- APPROPRIATELY
AND TO FIND OF THE STAFF THAT
SUPPORT OUR ENTIRE FEEL SILLY
STORIES IN CONSTRUCTION
PROGRAM. SO THOSE ARE CRITICAL
EXPENSES ON THAT THESE FUNDS
ARE COVERING AND DUE TO LACK OF
THE ONGOING REVENUES WE DO NEED
ON AN ONGOING SOLUTION AND THAT
SOLUTION AT THIS JUNCTURE
DEFINITELY LOOKS LIKE A GENERAL.
AND THE QUESTIONS- IN FREEDOM
TO RESPOND. OKAY FINANCES TO
REMIND YOU THAT YOU. YES. YOU
KNOW MY DEPARTMENT FINANCE. I
JUST LIKE TO ASK THAT THE
INDIAN CURRY BELIEVES ACCOUNT
IS A SUB ACCOUNT OF THE STATE
FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION FUND BY
CONSOLIDATING THESE FUNDS THIS
ALLOWS FOR THE STATE STATE
COURT FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION
REMAIN SOLVENT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR WITH ALPHA EIGHT GENERAL
FUND OBLIGATION FOR MORE ABOUT
THE FUND TO MAINTAIN EXISTING
SERVICE LEVELS FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S FACILITIES PROGRAM AS
WELL AS MENTIONED- IN A DAY IN
ADDITION CONSOLIDATION PERMITS
BUDGETARY. EFFICIENCIES WITHIN
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH THROUGH THE
REDUCTION OF SPECIAL FUNDS
SINCE EACH ONE OF THESE SPECIAL
FUNDS SB ADMINISTERED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS WELL AS
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE STAFF
IT'S LESS ADMINISTRATIVE WORK
FOR THEM TO COMPLETE. IN
REGARDS TO THE L. A. S.
RECOMMENDATION ON A IN COMBINED
MOVING RESPONSE TO THE GENERAL
FUND I'M HERE SAYING- ANYWAY
WE'RE ESSENTIALLY MAKING FOR
FACILITY MAINTENANCE WE WOULD
LOOK AT ME REVENUE FROM CORE
ASSEMBLY MAINTENANCE AND THIS
WOULD COMPETE WITH OTHER
FUNDING FOR OTHER PURPOSES.
INSIDE THE GENERAL FUND FOR
EDUCATION AND HEALTHCARE. WELL
IN THE FUTURE THE SOLUTION
WOULD BE TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THE FUTURE- TO KEEP THE FUND'S
SOLVENCY THIS. IS WINDY AS
SIGNIFICANT AS MOVING. THE
PROGRAM ENTIRELY TO THE GENERAL
FUND. OKAY THANK YOU- L. A.
PLEASE. ANY DALY WITH THE L. A.
L. SO WE ARE GOING TO PROVIDE
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR BOTH
ISSUES FIVE AND SIX AND GATHER
BECAUSE- ISSUE FIVE PERTAINS TO
KIND OF EXISTING OBLIGATIONS
SUPPORTED BY THE ACCOUNTS AND
THEN YOUR ISSUE SIX- WHICH IS
FOR ADDITIONAL NEW TRAVEL
CONSTRUCTION OBLIGATIONS ARE
FOCUSING ON THE FUTURE AND SO
AS A LEGISLATURE IS
CONSIDERING. AFFECTED WE
RESTARTING CHILDHOOD
CONSTRUCTION WE THOUGHT IT
COULD BE HELPFUL TO KIND OF
PACKAGE OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
TOGETHER SO YOU CAN SEE HOW
THEY KIND OF INTERTWINED WITH
ONE ANOTHER. SO AT MINIMUM WE
ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THE
CONSOLIDATION OF THE TWO
ACCOUNTS. BECAUSE IT DOES DELAY
THE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
INSOLVENCY IN THE BUDGET YEAR
BUT WE WOULD ALSO EMPHASIZE
THAT IT REALLY MAKES NO SENSE
TO MAINTAIN SEPARATE ACCOUNTS
WHEN BOTH ARE GOING TO BECOME
INSOLVENT ANYWAY- BECAUSE BOTH
PLANS ARE GOING TO BE AND SALAS
AND THERE IS THIS QUESTION
ABOUT HOW THIS INSOLVENCY WOULD
BE ADDRESSED THAT'S NOT PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL-
WE ARE ACTUALLY RECOMMENDING
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ACTUALLY
GO FURTHER- WE ARE RECOMMENDING
THAT THE ACCOUNTS TO BE
ELIMINATED AND THAT FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR TRIAL FOR
CONSTRUCTION BE SHIFTED OVER TO
THE GENERAL FUND- SO. ABSENCE
ANY CHANGES SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES ARE ALREADY
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO MAINTAIN-
EXISTING OBLIGATIONS WHICH MOST
NOTABLY IS FINANCING PAYMENTS
FOR A TRUCKER CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS THAT WE HAVE ALREADY
COMPLETED. AND TO GIVE YOU AN
IDEA OF WHAT WE MEAN BY
SIGNIFICANT OUR ESTIMATE IS
THAT AROUND A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD BE NEEDED BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. AND GENERAL FUND WOULD BE
NEEDED THROUGH THE NEXT FIFTEEN
OR SIXTEEN YEARS IT WOULD
DECLINE IN THE OUT YEARS. AS WE
KIND OF COMPLETELY PAY OFF THE
FACILITIES BUT IT'S NOT AN IN
SYNC IT SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY AND SO BY SHIFTING THINGS
OVER. IT ENSURES THAT ALL OF
THE GENERAL FUND RESPONSIBILITY
THE OBLIGATIONS ARE FULLY
ACCOUNTED FOR. WHEN WE ARE
CONSIDERING- SPENDING FROM THE
GENERAL FUND AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY TO
CONSIDER THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONDITION AND DETERMINING ITS
GENERAL FUND SPENDING
PRIORITIES WITH ALL OF THAT
FULL KNOWLEDGE AT ALL THAT IS
BEING ACCOUNTED FOR. ALSO IN
LINE WITH THIS ALL OF THE NON
CONSTRUCTION RELATED
EXPENDITURES SUCH AS FOR
FACILITY- MODIFICATIONS IN FOR
TRIAL COURT OPERATIONS WOULD
ALSO SHIFT OVER. AND SO THEY
WOULD NEED TO BE AN
APPROPRIATION TO MAINTAIN THAT
LEVEL OF SUPPORT. FINALLY WE
ARE ALSO RECOMMENDING. THAT ALL
OF THE CONSTRUCTION RIGHT. ALSO
LEAD TO PAY INTO THE GENERAL SO
THAT THERE'S STILL A BILL. TO
OFFSET THE X. SHIFTED OVER TO
THE GENERAL FUND AND SO- YOU
KNOW THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
RAISES CONCERNS ABOUT
COMPETITION WITH OTHER THINGS.
THE GENERAL FUND IS GOING TO
HAVE TO PAY FOR THESE
OBLIGATIONS WHETHER THEY ARE
NEW OBLIGATIONS MOVING FORWARD
OR OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY IN HER. WHEN THAT
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE ACCOUNT
THE ENVISIONED THAT THE
CONSTRUCTION ACCOUNTS WOULD
HAVE SUFFICIENT REVENUE TO
BASICALLY PAY FOR THEM THAT'S
KIND OF HOW LANGUAGE WAS
ESTABLISHED. GIVEN THE
DECLINING FROM OFFLINE IF YOU
REVENUES AS A JUDICIAL BRANCH
TALKED ABOUT THE GENERAL FUND
WILL NOT LIKELY HAVE TO STEP UP
AND BASICALLY PAY FOR THEM AND
SO THERE IS ALREADY GOING TO BE
AN IMPACT. ON GENERAL FUND
SPENDING PRIORITIES AS A
LEGISLATURE THINKING ABOUT BACK.
MOVING FORWARD. AS YOU'RE GOING
TO BE DISCUSSING ON THE NEXT
ISSUE ITEM WE ARE RECOMMENDING
APPROVING THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH TO FINDING ANY NEW
PROJECTS FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
THAT MEANS THAT YOU'LL BE
YOU'LL BE APPROVING PROJECTS
SEPARATE FROM THE CONSTRUCTION
YES SEPARATE FROM THE AMOUNT OF
CRIMINAL FINES YOU REVENUE
THAT'S COMING AND YOU DON'T
NEED YOU KNOW I NEED TO THINK
ABOUT THAT ANYMORE. BUT IT
WOULD ALSO ENSURE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS FULLY AWARE OF
THE TOTAL COST OF THE PROJECT.
AND THE IMPACT OF THE HAVE ON
THE GENERAL PLAN AND SO THAT
WILL HELP YOU WEIGH THEM
AGAINST YOUR OTHER GENERAL FUND
PRIORITY- HOWEVER WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE WHICH SPECIFIC
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS TO FIND
BASED. ON ITS PRIORITIES WHICH
MAY OR MAY NOT NCLUDE ANY OF
THE PROJECTS THAT YOU'LL BE
DISCUSSING IN THE NEXT AGENDA
ITEM. FOR THE TWELVE PROJECTS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY SLATED TO
COME ONLINE IN THE FOUR YEARS
AFTER. THE BUDGET YEAR. AND
THIS IS BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT DIFFER FROM
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH'S
METHODOLOGY AND HOW THEY DID
THEIR- REASSESSMENT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEN SO FOR
EXAMPLE THE LEGISLATURE- MIGHT
DEFINE OR WAIVE THE CRITERIA
DIFFERENTLY. OR THEY MIGHT
THINK THAT ADDITIONAL FACTORS
COULD ALSO BE IMPORTANT AS
WELL. AND SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT%
CONFLICTS ARE COMMON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- SO- I THIS IS FOR I
THINK THIS FOR FINANCE OR FOR
THE- FOR THE BRANCH.
CONSOLIDATION OF THE FUNDS
SOUNDS ARE REASONABLE AS LA
POINTED OUT BUT HOW DOES THE
BRANCH INTENT TO ADDRESS THE
POTENTIAL INSOLVENCY ISSUE. OF
THE CONSOLIDATED FUND. IN THE
OUT YEARS. JUST REMINDED
PARTNER FINANCE ANALYSIS IS
CURRENTLY IS CURRENTLY PLANNED
IT THIS WOULD BE SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE ARE CURRENTLY DOING FOR
THE TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND
WHERE WE REJECTED BACK FILL FOR
THE YEAR AND AT A LATER POINT
IN THE IMAGINATION MAKE IT AND
JUST MAKE IT BACK FEEL THE FINE
TO MAKE SURE IT'S GOING TO BE
SOLVING. FOR THE BUDGET YEAR SO
REALLY JUST. BE GENERAL FUND
BACK INTERACTION. OKAY
COLLEAGUES AND QUESTIONS NO
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU THE
BILL HOLD OPEN ISSUE SIX THIS
IS A CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS.
YES MADAM CHAIRMAN THE SYSTEMS
LIKE COMPUTER WHICH AGAIN
CONGESTION COUNCIL I WANT TO
GIVE YOU A BRIEF OVERVIEW- THIS
ISSUE ON HAS A SPECIFIC
PROPOSAL IN THE BUDGET YEAR- OF
EIGHT TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND AND SIXTY
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN LEAST REVENUE BONDS
AUTHORITY TO PAY FOR PROJECTS
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET YEAR-
THEY ARE SPECIFIC. LAKE COUNTY-
LAKE NEAR LAKE PORT TOWN HOUSE
OF SIXTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
FOR PERFORMANCE CRITERION
DESIGN BUILD PHASES- THE
MENDOCINO COUNTY NEWS HIGH
COURT HOUSES THREE POINT THREE
MILLION OR PERFORMANCE CRITERIA
UNFAZED A- LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MASTER PLAN STUDY MONEY OF TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
NEVADA COUNTY NEW NEVADA CITY
COURTHOUSE US NINE HUNDRED
SEVENTY TWO MILLION. NINE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
EXCUSE ME FOR ALSO STUDY- THESE
ARE- THE FIRST FOUR PROJECTS
IN- WHAT IS PROPOSED THE
GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET OF A FIVE
YEAR- FOURTEEN. PROPOSAL OF
OVER POINT BILLION- THERE
COUNCIL- AFTER. REQUIREMENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE ENGAGING IN A
REASSESSMENT OF OUR ALL OF OUR
FACILITY NEEDS THAT WERE- AND
WE COMPLETED THAT AND WE HAVE A
PART IS A PRIORITIZED LIST. ON
THIS PROPOSAL SECONDLY MOVES TO
THAT LIST OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS TO ADDRESS THE MOST
CRITICAL AND IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF
THE BRANCH FOR FACILITY.
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM AGAIN HAVE
A HELL OF A FOR MAKING AND-
JENKINSON AVAILABLE RESPOND AND
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. I WOULD NOTE THAT WE
ALONG WITH THESE PROPOSALS
INCLUDED TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE-
THAT WOULD- AUTHORIZE DESIGN
BUILD- DELIVERY METHOD- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT IS CURRENTLY
USED NOT STATE. FARM HAS A LONG
TRACK RECORD WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
INTO THAT USE AND THAT PROCESS
WHICH WE BELIEVE WILL RESULT IN
A MORE EXPEDITED PROJECT
DELIVERY. AND CHEAPER UP
PROJECT COSTS AS. COMPARED TO
OUR CURRENT DELIVERY METHOD.
THANK YOU. OKAY ON ON ISSUE SIX
ITSELF- BINANCE PLEASE.
FRIEDMAN ROBIN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. THE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT ALL FOUR
OF THESE PROPOSALS IN ADDITION
TO THAT THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE WHICH IS PROPOSAL
NUMBER SEVEN OR SHOULD NEVER
SEVEN ON THE AGENDA. FOR.
ELLIE- PLEASE. I NEED ONLY WITH
THE L. A. L. ON ISSUES SIX- NO
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS- ADD TO THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT ON YOUR PREVIOUS
ITEM ON ISSUE SEVEN WHICH IS
THE DESIGN BUILD LANGUAGE WE'VE
GOT WE HAVE NO CONCERNS ABOUT
PROPOSAL. THANK YOU. OKAY WELL
WE WERE JUST ON SIX- HE JUMPED
THE SEVEN HERE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS ON SIX AND THEY WILL
JUMP INTO SEVEN NO OKAY SO NO
QUESTIONS ON SIXTH AND. THREE
ON SEVEN DESIGN BUILD AUTHORITY.
DID YOU COVER THAT THE YEAH MY-
I DON'T CARE- IN MY MIND THAT
PUT THE PUT TOGETHER BY
APOLOGIES AS WE DID- WE DID
ADDRESS BUT IT IS REAL REAL
LANGUAGE TO AUTHORIZE A NEW
DELIVERY MODEL ON AT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROGRAM. AGAIN THE
IN THE EXPECTATION HOPE IS THAT
RESULTS IN A QUICKER AND
CHEAPER METHOD. DELIVERY VAN
WHAT IS CURRENTLY AUTHORIZED
WITHIN THE COUNCIL AND- WE
CRESCENTA SUPPORT- OF- THE
PROBLEM FINANCE ON THIS AGAIN
HAVE A- PROGRAM EXPERTS
AVAILABLE. FOR MAKING JACKSON
SAYING. TO RESPOND ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. GET I
IF YOU COULD JUST GET A LITTLE
BIT MORE INTO- WHITE YOU'RE
PROPOSING THAT OVER THE
CURRENT. DESIGN BID BUILD
PROCESS. WHAT LED YOU TO. FROM
TO THIS. AND THEN YOU KNOW JUST
FOR TO US THE DALLAS MCCORMICK
IN JACK AND SEEM TO PROVIDE
THAT THE DEEPER AND RESPONSE.
HERE'S A MELHOR MIXED AUDIO IS
NOT WORKING WILL TURN OVER TO
MR SAYING ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- THIS IS JACK
AND SAME INTERNATIONAL COUNCIL
SORT. BUT TARGETED WE HAVE.
BOMBINGS SECTION SEVEN THREE
NINE ONE SEVEN THE IS WAS
LIMITED FOR THE DESIGNS ARE
CORRECT METHODOLOGY THAT WE'RE
USING IS NOT DESIGNED AND BUILT
BY CONSTRUCTION MANAGER AT RISK
SO WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS BECAUSE
WE HOLD TWO SEPARATE CONTRACTS
ONE WITH ARCHITECT OR DESIGN
TEAM AND ONE WITH A CONTRACTOR.
WHO IS ACTUALLY BUILDING THE
PROJECT. THERE IS A DISCONNECT
BETWEEN THE TWO AND WE THE
OWNER TAKES ADDITIONAL RISK
BECAUSE OF THE ACT. OF THE ACT
IF THERE IS A DESIGN ISSUE WE
ARE ON THE HOPE TO GET THAT
CORRECTED BUT THE CONTRACTOR BY
MOVING TO THE DESIGN BUILD
DELIVERY METHOD. WE WOULD
ELIMINATE THE ACTRESS THAT
WRESTLING SHIFT OVER TO THE
DESIGN BUILD AND HE BECAUSE LAW
IT WILL BE ON THE CONTRACTOR TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE THE CAR IN
THE DESIGN BUILD METHODOLOGY
THOUGH. THE OWNERS ONLY SOLD
CONTRACTORS WITH THE CONTRACTOR
AND THE DESIGNERS UNDER THE
CONTRACTOR SO THAT IS THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR SHIFTING-
OUR RISK AND REDUCING OUR RISK
FOR CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS. I
WOULD ALSO MENTION BACK. ON ON
THE AVERAGE THE DESIGN. IS MUCH
MORE FASTER THAN CMR. PROCESS
BECAUSE WE CAN DO. THE STOCK
MUCH ARE A THE PACKAGES GETTING
BY THE CONGRESS AND GET BERMAN
BY THE STREETS MARSHALL. WELL
WHAT WE ARE REQUESTING IS OUR-
RESTORATION OF OUR PREVIOUS
AUTHORITY UNDER THE COMMON
SECTION CALLED SOME OF THREE
NINETY ONE POINT SEVEN. IN
WHICH WE WERE LIMITED TO FIVE
STATE FACILITIES- WOULD THAT
ALSO INCLUDED THE- STATE OFFICE
FACILITIES PRISONS AND THE
COURSE CELEBRITIES. AND IN THE
NEW TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WELL
WE ARE GONNA MATTER THAT SEEMS
OF PREVIOUS. OF LANGUAGE AND
ALSO THE LANGUAGE THAT IS FAR
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TWO OF. TO
ALLOW STUDENTS TO DESIGN. OKAY-
IN JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION ON
THAT DOES THIS- CHANGE THE
NUMBER PROPOSED. OR COULD IT
CHANGE THE NUMBER POLLS AND- IN
FUTURE IN THE FUTURE- SO THE
CHAIN THE NUMBER OF HURDLES- IT-
IT DOESN'T HAVE AN IMPACT BY
TWO EIGHT. THE ONLY WOULD BE
THAT WILL BE A TO ACHIEVE SAME
ARE. WHICH OF THOSE. ERRORS AND
OMISSIONS ROSE BECAUSE SHIP YOU
MCCARTY. AND WE WILL HAVE SEEN
BECAUSE WE STARTED THE
CONSTRUCTION ALREADY ARE STILL
THE ESCALATION CALLS TO THE
START OF CONSTRUCTION AND THE
SOLUTION BECAUSE TO. MAKE PART
OF CONSTRUCTION ALL THE RULES
ARE VERY USEFUL THE PROJECT
SHOULD BE CHEAPER AND RUN MUCH
FASTER. SO THE PRODUCTIVITY
WILL INCREASE. C. M. CHANGE AND
ARE IN THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS.
OKAY. THANK COLLEAGUES MANY
QUESTIONS NO NOT HERE OKAY-
THAT'S THE LAST STRAW THAT'S
THE LAST ISSUE ARE I THANK THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH IN THE FINANCE
AND- BOMB L. A. O. OUR STAFF I
JUST WANT TO- JUST SAY A FEW
THINGS BEFORE WE AND- I HAVE
BEEN TALKING WITH SENATOR
UMBERG CHAIR OF SENATE
JUDICIARY AND- WE HAVE SOME
SORT OF COMMON. ISSUES THAT
WE'VE BEEN- DISCUSSING RELATED
TO EFFICIENCIES AND ALSO TO THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE OF THE
COURT HOUSES- CENTER BERG
BEHIND HAVING A JOINT HEARING
OF THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEES ON. ON
SOME OF THESE ARE ASPECTS- BUT
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE FOR
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH THAT DOM. I
ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE IN THE
FISHING SEASON MODERNIZE IN OUR
COURTS BUT WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL THAT
THAT WE CONTINUE TO ENHANCE.
ACCESS TO PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE
HARDEST TIME USING OUR COURTS
ARE AND WHO HAVE THE GREATEST
NEED- GOING TO COURT IS NEVER
EASY FOR ANYBODY. AND THERE'S A
LOT OF TRAUMA IN THOSE CASES IN
THE- WHAT PEOPLE ARE FACING-
AND WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE KEEP THAT IN MIND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
EFFICIENCY THAT IT'S NOT AT AT
THE AT THE RISK OF. OF FURTHER
HURTING OR ARE ON THE NINE-
ACCESS- AND YOU KNOW A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS LIKE IMMIGRANTS-
THOSE IN NEED OF LANGUAGE
SERVICES INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES IS ARE ALL. SHOULD
BE RIGHT AT THE TOP OF OUR LIST
AS MUCH AS MODERNIZING IS- IT
CAN MEAN. NEW TECHNOLOGY CAN'T
MEAN- CANNOT MEAN BETTER ACCESS
FOR SOME AND BETTER EFFICIENCY
FOR SOME BUT BROUGHT ME IN THE
GAP FOR OTHERS AND- I SAY THIS
BECAUSE DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
IN MANY WAYS WERE APPLAUDING-
THE REMOTE PROCESS AND THE
TECHNOLOGY AND WE CONTINUOUSLY
LEAVE BEHIND PEOPLE ARE IN THAT
DIGITAL DIVIDE WHO JUST CANNOT
OR DON'T KNOW HOW TO USE THIS
TECHNOLOGY OR DON'T HAVE
ACCESS. TO THIS TECHNOLOGY- AND
I DO WONDER. ARE REITERATE OUR
OR- SO WITH MY CALL IN CORTEZ
HE SAID ABOUT- EVICTIONS ON THE
POTENTIALS OF THESE EVICTIONS
ARE WE PREPARED TO HANDLE THE
NUMBER OF CASES. AT THE END OF
THE OF THE MORATORIUM- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE A TEMPORARY RESTRAINT
WE FIGHT FROM THE CRISIS BUT
OUR COURTS WILL OUR COURTS BE
IN A POSITION WE EXPECT OUR
COURTS TO BE IN A POSITION TO
HANDLE THIS. FANDOM FINALLY IS
JUST BASED ON THE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE- ON THE DEPENDENCY
COURTS- I KNOW JUST THE LOS
ANGELES COURT SYSTEM CONSISTS
OF TWENTY EIGHT CORDS- AND THE
LAWYERS DEPENDENCY LAWYERS
HANDLE MORE THAN TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND LOW INCOME PARENTS ON
ANY. ONE GIVEN DAY- A
DISPROPORTIONATELY LARGE NUMBER
OF THOSE CLIENTS ARE WITHIN MY
DISTRICT COULD COME PROUD TO
REPRESENT THOSE COMMUNITIES-
AND THE YOU KNOW THE COUNCIL
HAS DETERMINED THAT CASELOADS
FOR PARENTS AND- CHILDREN
ATTORNEY SHOULD NOT EXCEED A
HUNDRED FORTY. CASES PER
ATTORNEY- BUT CURRENTLY IT'S
OVER A HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
CASES PER ATTORNEY AS OUR
INFORMATION SHOWS- AND REALLY
THEY SHOULD BE AT A HUNDRED
CASES PER ATTORNEY. SO I RAISE
THAT AS A AS AN ADDITIONAL
CONCERN EVEN THOUGH THERE
WASN'T A PARTICULAR. OKAY WE'LL
CONTINUE TO SEE- AND- AND
DISCUSS THOSE ISSUES I THINK
NOW WE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY WITH MY PERSONAL PUBLIC-
OKAY WITH THE- FIND. OKAY HERE
WE GO SO- WE'RE GOING OUT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT- WE WILL NOW
MOVE INTO ON TO ANYONE WANTING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF
HEARINGS TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS INCLUDING
PROTOCOLS. COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY TODAY I'M GOING TO
ASK THAT. HE WITH. MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMON
KEEP THE REMARKS WITHIN ONE
MINUTE. NOW LET'S BEGIN ITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. ST NONE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM ONE TWELVE.
SEEN NONE OF OUR SENATE IT
STAFF WILL CHANGE THE SCREEN
VIEWED TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM
DONE FIFTY JUST SHOWED ME RIGHT.
IF THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE
OVERFLOW ROOM THEY WILL TESTIFY
INDIVIDUALLY BUT WE DON'T SEE
ANY. OF WE MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN. MON
MISTER MISS MODERATOR SOMEONE
THERE. OKAY. WE HEAR ARE WE
OKAY. CALLING ON THE MODERATOR.
BACKSPACE HEARING LIKE THIS
THAT'S A SURPRISING. IT DOESN'T
CALL. A. EVERYBODY L. HELLO YES
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE MODERATOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU FOR BEFORE
PUBLIC COMMENT YES SIR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
THE TELEPHONE. THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
COMMENTS IN Q. FORGOTTEN LINE.
HI MISTER MODERATE- CAN YOU
GIVE ME THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY. AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE SEVEN. OKAY GO
AHEAD. NINE EIGHTEEN ONE EIGHT
GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR- MEMBERS
MIKE CARROLL FROM THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING TODAY- I
HAVE A COUPLE OF COMMENTS ON ON
ITEMS CHIU ON THE ISSUE OF THE
SELF HELP CENTERS I WAS VERY
INTERESTED IN THE DISCUSSION
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAD BOND FOR
REPORTERS I THINK OF SENATOR
CORTESE CENTER NEWMAN'S POINTS
ARE WELL TAKEN WE REALLY DO
NEED TO FOCUS ON MAKING SURE
THEIR ADEQUATE PROVISION OF
COURT REPORTERS. IN COURTROOMS
AS WE HEAR ALL OF THESE
UNLAWFUL DETAINER CASE THAT MAY
BE COMING WE CANNOT BRING
APPEALS LEGAL SERVICE ADVOCATE
THAT ONCE WE HAVE A RECORD OF
THE HEARING AND IF THERE'S NO
COURT REPORTER WE HAVE NO
RECORD THAT THIS IS REALLY
CRUCIAL SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED THIS
YEAR. SECOND I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS ITEM FOR YOUR GENDER
WHICH DEALS WITH THE ONLINE
QUARTERS USE THAT UNIFICATION
TRAFFIC COURT PROF. PROGRAMS-
WELL APPRECIATE THE ADMIN.
EFFORTS TRY TO- ACCESS- ALLOW
DO- JUDICATA TAKE ONLINE. I
THINK WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DATA
THAT'S IN THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL'S REPORT THIS YEAR IT
REALLY HIGHLIGHTS AN INEQUITY
THAT WE'RE BEGINNING TO SEE.
THE MAPS- IN SOME YOU KNOW
PERHAPS MORE LIBERAL COUNTIES
IN THE STATE WE ARE SEEN.
PRETTY HIGH DISCOUNTS ON THE
NUMBER ON HOW MUCH PEOPLE ARE
GETTING PRODUCTIONS IN THEIR
TRAFFIC TICKETS WHEREAS IN
OTHER COUNTIES WORSE NOT SEEN
THOSE REDUCTIONS. OUR
PREFERENCE RANKING WITH EXPRESS
IS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
WOULD BE TO SIMPLY REDUCE OR
ELIMINATE THE FEES THAT ARE
ATTACHED TO TRAFFIC FINES WHICH
CURRENTLY- THERE I THINK
THERE'S A LOT OF AN ADD ON. TO
THESE TRAFFIC TICKETS WE THINK
THIS WOULD BE A MORE EQUITABLE
APPROACH THAT THE LEGISLATURE
COULD TAKE THAT WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT NO MATTER WHERE YOU ARE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU
WOULD GET THOSE DISCOUNTS
APPLIED AND NOT HAVE IT BE AT
THE DISCRETION. OF JUDGES IN
INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES. WE YOU
KNOW WE OVERALL ARE ARE NOT IN
FAVOR OF THE EXPANSION AT THIS
TIME WE DO AGREE T. L. A. ON
THAT- BUT WE ARE WILLING TO
WORK WITH YOU MINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE TO FIND A-
COMPROMISE. BUT WE DO THINK ON
ELIMINATION OF MANY OF THE
SPECIES IS THE PROPER APPROACH
TO REALLY BRINGING JUSTICE. TO
THE TRAFFIC A COURT SITUATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THANK. YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
ARE NOT COMMON LINE TWELVE LINE
WILL TWO THREE TO GO AHEAD. MAY
BE CENTERED ON BEHALF OF AT THE
ARE YOU CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
COURT EMPLOYEES I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE PROPOSAL
IN THE JANUARY BUDGET AUGMENT
TRIAL COURTS OPERATING BUDGET
AS WELL AS YESTERDAY'S
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT SUCH
AUGMENTATION WILL BE
SUPPLEMENTED BY THE
RESTORATION. OF CUTS- VIA LAST
YEAR'S TRACKER- WE ARE HOWEVER
CONCERNED ABOUT THE WITHDRAWAL
OF ELEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL THIS IS OF
ACCOMMODATING AN INCREASE IN
WORKLOAD RESULTING FROM THE
EXPLORATION OF THAT THE
AFFECTION MORATORIUM VIA. AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT. HOUSE
SUBSEQUENTLY. THAT NINETY ONE
WE WILL IN. OF THAT ADDITIONAL
FUNDING ON TOP OF THE ELEVEN
POINT SEVEN WILL BE NECESSARY
TO ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND WHEN THAT BUDGET.
DISCRIMINATION IS MADE IT HOT
INCLUDES FUNDINGFOR COURT
REPORTERS MAKE SURE THAT YOU
CAN BE DATA CAN BE COMPLIED- WE
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION THAT WE HEARD
ABOUT. WORKERS AND WANT TO THE
CEMENT WE DISAGREE IN THE
COMMENTS THAT ONE OF THE
LEADING MADE REGARDING- THE
ISSUE BEING COMPLICATED IT'S
NOT COMPLICATED AT ALL MAKING
SURE COURT HIGHER SUFFICIENT
COURT ORDERS DON'T LET ME
OFFICE. BELT FOR AWHILE WENDY
AND THAT WE FIND THE- TRIAL
COURT TRANSCRIPT INCREASED THAT
HASN'T BEEN INCREASED IN THIRTY
YEARS IS THE NUMBER ONE WAY TO
MAKE SURE. GUARANTEE WE HAVE
SUFFICIENT ORDERS TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT. WE HAVE A CALM TO MY
TWENTY TO ONE LINE IS A- GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS RIO
SHARP I WORK AT THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA- AND
WERE INVOLVED IN THE DEBT FREE
JUSTICE COALITION AND THE BACK
ON THE ROAD COALITION AND I'M
PROVIDING PUBLIC COMMENT ABOUT
ISSUE NUMBER THREE THE ABILITY
TO PAY EXPANSION- AND I WOULD
URGE YOU ALL TO REJECT THAT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL PROPOSAL AND
INSTEAD OF EXPANDING THE ONLINE
TOOL- I URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
ELIMINATE DOUBLE ATTACHMENT.
THOSE LATE FEES BUT OFTEN
AMOUNT TO THREE HUNDRED
DOLLARS- OF COURSE WE NEED TO
REDUCE THE COST OF COURT FINES
AND FEES WERE TOTALLY IN
AGREEMENT THERE THERE ARE FAR
TOO HIGH BUT THE ONLINE TOOL IS
NOT THE BEST APPROACH TO DO
THAT- FIRST TOPIC PRIVILEGES
THOSE WITH THE WHERE WITH ALL
TO GET ONLINE AND COMPLETE THE
ONLINE TOOL. FOR THOSE OF AYE
TABLE ACCESS DAY MEETING
VIRTUALLY TODAY THAT MIGHT NOT
SEEM LIKE MUCH BUT IT DOES ACT
AS A HURDLE FOR SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT NEED THAT TOOL FOR USING
THAT ONLINE APPROACH TO LOWER
CAR. INSURANCE THAT MANY OF
THOSE WHO NEED AFFORDABILITY
THE MOST WILL NOT RECEIVE AT.
THE ONLINE TOOL ALSO HELPS
PEOPLE IN DIFFERENT COUNTY
DIFFERENTLY IT TENDS TO DO MORE
FOR THOSE IN SAN FRANCISCO THAN
THOSE IN VENTURA COUNTY FOR
EXAMPLE- WHY WOULD WE CHOOSE
THE STRATEGY PRED DRAFTING
COSTS THAT HELP SOME MORE THAN
OTHERS THOSE IN TERMS OF GO
DON'T DESERVE MORE MERCY THAN
THOSE WHO VENTURE OUT. AND WE
SHOULD COME UP WITH A STRATEGY
THAT'S MORE GEOGRAPHICALLY
UNIFORM. THERE'S JUST NO SENSE
IN LOADING PEOPLE UP WITH MATH
AT THAT FIRST AND THEN OFFERING
THEM RELIEF ON THE BACK AND WE
NEED FRONT AND REFORM AND FOR
THAT REASON WE NEED TO
ELIMINATE OF WHAT THAT MEANT.
CIVIL ATTACHMENTS ARE AN
EXCESSIVE PENALTY EITHER OFTEN
THAT THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS EVEN
WHEN THE ORIGINAL FINE WITH
ONLY TWENTY FIVE OR FIFTY
DOLLARS- HE CAN BE TEN TIMES AS
MUCH AS THE ACTUAL FIND THAT
THE LEGISLATORS AFTER THE
INFRACTION AND THAT'S JUST
RIDICULOUS AND UNFAIR. IT WAS
OFTEN ALSO HAVE VERY DIVERGENT
A FAX FROM DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES THOSE COMMUNITIES
LEAST ABLE TO PAY THEIR FINES
PROMPTLY ARE THOSE MOST. LIKELY
TO BE HAD WITH THE FROM NORMAL
AND NORMA'S FINE. AND THE CAN.
FACE THE MOST. TO APPEAR IN
COURT. ARE THE MOST TO GET
DIVORCED. SO WOULD YOU KNOWS.
THAT LLOWING PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR. ARE FACING THE
HIGHEST RATE THE WHAT THAT
MEANT. IF YOU HAVE CASH YOU THE
FINE PRINT OF THE AT THAT. BUT
IF YOU DON'T HAVE CASH.
AVAILABLE OR HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING TO COURT YOU CAN EXPECT
TO BE FINED HEAVILY FOR THAT.
IT'S JUST NOT A FAIR EQUITABLE
PRACTICE AND IT'S ONE WE SHOULD
AND- ANYWAY SHOT THAT WILL
HAPPENED DOESN'T ALLOW. WITH
OUR CURRENT EFFORT ADVANCE. IN
THE COURTS SO PLEASE CONSIDER.
INSTEAD OF MOVING FORWARD ON
THAT ONLINE EDUCATION TOOL I
TAKE THE WILL POWER THAT YOU
HAVE TO REDUCE COSTS AND
INCREASE AFFORDABILITY. AND
TAKE THE FUNDS THAT WOULD BE
SPENT ON IT. AND REALLY URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO ELIMINATE
DOUBLE EFFECT MEANT BASS BACK
THE WAY TO. ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM. THANK YOU ON
AFFORDABILITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE NINETEEN ONE NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS MIKE
BELOW SPEAKING FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA DEFENSE COUNSEL ARE
BE EXCEEDINGLY BRIEF. WE ARE
CIVIL PRACTITIONERS OPERATING-
DEFENDING CIVIL CASES IN
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH OUR FRIENDS IN THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS AND THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. ON WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE REASONABLE-
UNIFORMITY ACROSS THE STATE AND
GET CIVIL CASES MOVING WE KNOW.
THAT THERE IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
IMPERATIVE ON CRIMINAL CASES
AND AS THE CHAIR MENTIONED YOU
MAY HAVE QUITE THE DAY LOSE. OF
THE VISION MATTERS COMING UP
WHEN THAT MORATORIUM EXPIRES.
BUT CIVIL CASES GENERAL'S
CASES. HAVE TENDED TO BE AT THE
BACK OF THE LINE- NECESSARILY
AS WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER TO
TRY TO FIND WAYS TO MOVE THESE
CASES FORWARD AND WERE STRONGLY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET AT A HOUSE REVISED
YESTERDAY. AND WOULD URGE
ADOPTION OF THAT- THE CIVIL
CASES- AND WE ARE WORKING ON
TECHNOLOGY IN WAYS THAT HAS A
CHAIR NOTED ARE. SPENT THEIR TO
ALL- WEEK WE NEED TO GET CIVIL
GENERAL CIVIL CASES WORKING AS
WELL AND FOR THAT WERE SUPPORT.
ABOUT THE BUDGET THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUR NEXT COMMENTS
FROM LINE FIFTEEN ONE FIVE YOU
MAY GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LAUREN KLEIN AND I AM
WOULD BE LEGAL AID ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT THE
NINETY NINE THAT LEGAL SERVICES
NONPROFIT THROUGHOUT THE STATE
TO PROVIDE FREE CIVIL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE. TO LOW INCOME
PEOPLE AND THAT ARE FUNDED
THROUGH THE- JUDICIAL BRANCH
BUDGET EQUAL ACCESS FUND- THANK
YOU JUDY COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
BRINGING UP IMPORTANT ISSUES
TODAY SUCH AS THE AVAILABILITY
OF LEGAL AID AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF COURT REPORTERS
AND THEY'RE VERY VERY URGENT
AND IMPORTANT. ISSUES TODAY I'D
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF MR
HELD WITHIN CHAD- FROM A FEW
MOMENTS AGO REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE AND THE AVAILABILITY
OF COURT REPORTERS CURRENTLY
LOW INCOME PEOPLE ARE NOT
GETTING THE COURT REPORTERS
THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED TO UNDER
THE LAW AND THAT'S AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED.
WITH RESPECT TO LEGAL AID
FUNDING TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
BUDGET I HOPE WE HAVE TE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE MORE
INFORMATION ON THIS ISSUE
PERHAPS IN THE FUTURE HEARING-
TO DISCUSS THE GREAT NEED FOR
MORE FUNDING CURRENTLY FUNDING
IS INSUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
RISING NEED A HAND IN THE FACE
OF OTHER FUNDING SHORTFALLS.
AND THEN YOU WILL ONLY INCREASE
WHEN ADDICTION THROUGH MAIL SO
I'M ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS GOING
TO BE CRUCIAL- IN THE MEANTIME
BUT WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT
INCREASES TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH BUDGET SPECIFICALLY
ISSUES ONCE YOUR TRIAL COURT
OPERATIONS AND- HUNDREDS OF
THOSE ARE ALSO KEEPING. AND
PRACTICES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CONNECT OUR NEXT COMMUNISTS
FROM TWENTY TWO ZERO PLEASE GO.
PLEASE STOP DATA CLAW TO THE
ONE MINUTE PLEASE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SURE THING- ARMATURE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TEN SPEED
ASSISTANT GENERAL MANAGER OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT OVER
ONE THOUSAND FRONTLINE SUPERIOR
COURT WORKERS IN THE COUNTY OF
ORANGE TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO
JUST THREE MILLION RESIDENTS.
WE ARE ALSO ENCOURAGING
EXPRESSED APPRECIATION FOR
INCREASING RESTORATION OF
FUNDING I DO ECHO WHAT MY
SISTER FROM AS HE AYE YOU SAID
REGARDING A COURT ORDER
TRANSCRIPT FUNDING I ALSO WANT
TO JUST POINT OUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF FINDING SELF HELP
CENTERS AND ALSO DON'T BE
CONFUSED IT'S SOMEWHAT OF A
MISNOMER. PUBLIC SERVANTS
ASSIST RESIDENTS THROUGH THE
MOST IMPORTANT MOMENT OF THEIR
LIFE ITSELF HELP CENTER SO
THERE THERE ARE STAFFING THAT
IS NEEDED SO THAT NEED TO BE
FUNDED ALSO I CANNOT DISAGREE
MORE THAN EARLIER
CHARACTERIZATION OFFERED THAT
THE TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
RESTORATION IS SOMEHOW NOT. THE
DAY TO DAY REALITY FOR FRONT
LINE WORKERS DEFINITELY SAYS
OTHERWISE A COALITION OF UNIONS
OF THE MOBBING FOR RESTORATION
FUNDING SINCE THE GREAT
RECESSION THESE PROBLEMS DO NOT
MAGICALLY GO AWAY WHEN COBIT
CAME AROUND AND A SUBSEQUENT
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR CUT
TO THE COURTS. WERE SIMPLY
RESTORING THE COURTS TO THEIR
UNDERFUNDED STATUS THAT
OCCURRED BECAUSE OF AUSTERITY
MEASURES AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC SO- BUT BETWEEN A MORE
POSITIVE STATE BUDGET POTENTIAL
MOMENTUM IN WASHINGTON DC WILK
LEGISLATURE CAN TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVENE AND
FINALLY BRING EQUITY TO LOCAL
JUSTICE CENTERS FRONTLINE
WORKERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT THANK YOU A
REMINDER IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
ME PRESS ONE FOR BY THE GO TO
LINE TWENTY THREE TO THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY ANGER FOR THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA COMMENTING.
WHILE ONLINE. HM ALLOWED OUR
COMMON THE LEFT CENTER. THANK
YOU FOR ACCURATE BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK THE DATA HI THE INEQUITIES
AND NEVER. BUT PEOPLE WITH THE
AND THE IS A- THE RIGHT. ACT OF
ACCOUNTED THEY GOT THE TICKET.
RATHER THAN IN IN EXPANDING THE
PILE ARE FONG I'VE BEEN USING
FUNDS OUT RIGHT ELIMINATE LIKE
THAT. THERE'S ONE SURE
EQUITABLE ACROSS THE- THERE'S
NOT COUNTY DEPENDING ALL THE-
STEP FORWARD MAKING SURE THAT
TRAPPED TICKETS. DOWN BELOW AND
FROM CORE THAT LOWER DRIVERS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY NOT.
AT THIS THERE ARE NO LAW AND-
MODERATOR YOU PLAY CHECK THE
LINE ONE AGAIN BE SURE WE HAVE
HEARD ALL OF THE PUBLIC.
CERTAINLY THERE IS ANYONE ELSE
IN QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE THERE IS SOMEONE WITH AN
OPERATOR WILL BE JUST A MOMENT.
WE HAVE ONE OTHER LINE IN Q. IS
LINE TWENTY TWO TWO TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
NUMBER IF IT'D BE AN ATTACK ON
BEHALF CONSUMER TREAT
THE CALIFORNIA. NIGHT NUMBER
ONE TRUCK OPERATION. THERE IS
GREAT SUFFERING RIGHT NOW AND
COMPLETE AGAIN I DISCUSSED
TODAY TRIAL THEY'VE BEEN
DELAYED FOR A YEAR OR LONGER.
CHILDREN CANNOT GET THE COURT
INTO THE NEED TO KEEP THE
BATTLE. TO GET THE FINES.
ELDERLY ARE DYING AT THEIR
TRIAL DATE GET AS RIGHT BY WITH
THEM. I'M A THIRD TRANSACTION
AND WERE ACROSS AROUND USED
BACKLOG PEOPLE WHO ARE AFFECTED
WILL BE GREAT BIRTH I. WE ALSO
ENCOURAGE THE GREATER YOU. OF
FROM HEARING AFTER. THANK OF
THE BUDGET TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. BROUGHT HEARING THERE
ISN'T TOOL TO GET YOUR- NOT THE
U. FOR YOU KNOW FOR. OUR
MEMBERSHIP CURRENT IS YOUR CALL
WAITING MY TO GET FROM A
HEARING. YEAH IN FAMILY APPLY
THE GOVERNOR AND THE- FOR
CALLING THE RESTORATION OF YOU
GET THE REDUCE FUND- QUESTION
PHARMACY DIRECTOR TO URGENT
NEEDS SUCH AS REDUCING. AND
INCREASE OF UP ON THE BIRTH
GOOD ATI THINK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FOR MY- ANYMORE.
THERE ARE NO NO NO NO NO IN Q.
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK- HAVING
HER FROM MOM OF THE- A
COLLEAGUES MISTER CRITTERS
ANYMORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
NO THANK YOU THROUGH A THOROUGH
HEARING THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BOB THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED THE
AGENDA FOR TODAY'S HEARING FOR
THE SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE. IS
ADJOURNED. BAM.